Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. for 44 years since the time we fought for and won the German Empire
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、免广告收听、提前解锁系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 the restishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是说，the rest is history.com。在自我们为争取并赢得德意志帝国而战以来的44年里
and our position in the world we have lived in peace and have protected the peace of Europe like a silent vow the feeling that animated everyone from the emperor down to the youngest soldier was this
以及我们在世界上的地位，我们一直生活在和平之中，并像遵守无声的誓言一样守护着欧洲的和平，从皇帝到最年轻的士兵，每个人心中洋溢的情感都是这样的
only in defence of a just cause shall our suit fly from its scabbard. The day has now come, then we must draw it against our wish and in spite of our sincere endeavours. Russia has set fire to the building. We are at war with Russia and France, a war that has been forced upon us.
唯有在捍卫正义事业时，我们的长剑才会出鞘。如今这一天已经到来，我们不得不违背意愿、不顾我们真诚的努力而拔剑。俄罗斯点燃了这座建筑。我们正在与俄国和法兰克福开战，这是一场强加给我们的战争。
Now the great hour of trial has struck for our people. But with clear confidence, we go forward to meet it. Our army is in the field. Our navy is ready for battle. Behind them stands the entire German nation. The entire German nation. United to the last man. and indeed woman
现在，我们民族伟大考验的时刻已经敲响。但我们满怀清醒的自信，向前迈进以迎接它。我们的军队已在野外。我们的海军已严阵以待。在他们身后站着整个德意志民族。整个德意志民族。团结到最后一个人，乃至女人
he should have said but he didn't because this is the 4th of August 1914 and the Chancellor of Germany Teobald Bettmann Holveg who was dressed in a dragoons uniform and was addressing the Reichstag he just wasn't a feminist was he Dominic
他本该这么说，但他没有，因为这是1914年8月4日，德国首相特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼·霍尔维格身穿龙骑兵制服，正在向帝国议会发表讲话，他只是个大男子主义者，不是吗，多米尼克
no he wasn't at all actually Tom I felt that that reading became more Germanic as it proceeded there was a bit of Tom Holland in there but you were progressing basically towards the Kaiser no I wasn't what I was doing there was conveying the sense of
不，他其实一点也不是，汤姆，我感觉那段朗读随着进行变得越来越有德意志味了，里面有一点汤姆·霍兰的影子，但你基本上是在朝着凯撒的方向发展啊，不，我不是，我刚才做的是在传达那种
a peaceful nation, maybe one of the most cultured, the most intellectually advanced nation in Europe and perhaps the world, slowly mutating into an army of spike-helmeted hans set on despoiling Belgium. You've gone there straight away. Wow. All right. Well, that's what we'll be talking about today, isn't it? As we begin a mighty series on the First World War.
一个爱好和平的国家的感觉，也许是欧洲甚至世界上最具文化、最具智力先进性的国家之一，正在缓慢突变成一支头戴尖顶盔、决心蹂躏比利时的汉斯军队。你直接就切入这个话题了。哇。好吧。好吧，这正是我们主要谈论的，不是吗？当我们开启关于第一次世界大战的宏大系列时。
So that is, you could argue, the speech that kicks off the First World War. It's the first global industrialized war. it kills about 20 million people. I think there's a fair case that it's the supreme, the defining modern calamity. Oh, I would say indisputably, wouldn't you? I mean, there's nothing to compare to it. Gaza, Ukraine. You can trace them back to, as it were, the original sin of that cataclysm in the 1910s and everything that flowed from it, I think. In this series, we're going to look at the first months of the war up to the end of 1914. So we'll be looking at the Battle of the Frontiers in which basically the Germans wipe the floor with the French and the British. The German advance on
所以你可以说，那是拉开第一次世界大战序幕的演讲。这是第一场全球工业化战争。它大约夺去了2000万人的生命。我认为有充分的理由认为它是至高无上、具有决定性的现代灾难。哦，我会说这是无可争议的，不是吗？我的意思是，没有什么能与之相比。加沙，乌克兰。你可以将它们追溯到20世纪10年代那场大灾变的“原罪”，以及由此衍生的一切，我认为。在这个系列中，我们将探讨战争的前几个月，直到1914年底。所以我们将探讨边境战役，在这场战役中，德国人基本上把法军和英军打得落花流水。德军向
Paris, the great turning of the tide at the Battle of the Marn, the very bloody struggle for EPR, and the so-called massacre of the innocence, a huge sort of German nationalist myth, the struggle between Germany and Russia in East Prussia, the rise of well-known figures on the rest is history, Hindenburg and Ludendorf, and the beginning of the end for the Austro-Hungarian Empire, and the Habsburg-Stalingrad, Tom. That's very exciting, because that's basically a combination of two very exciting things. But today, I think we should do the very beginning of the war and the German onslaught on plucky little Belgium. So the heroic defensive liege by the Belgians, the fall of Brussels, and the issue that becomes so important in Allied propaganda, the so-called, to use the terminology of the time, the rape of Belgium, the German reprisals and the atrocities against civilians in Belgium.
巴黎的推进，马恩河战役中大局的扭转，伊普尔极其血腥的争夺战，以及所谓的无辜者大屠杀——一种巨大的德意志民族主义神话，德国与俄国在东普鲁士的斗争，“历史的余烬”节目中熟知的人物兴登堡和鲁登endorff（鲁登道夫）的崛起，奥匈帝国和哈布斯堡王朝末日的开始，汤姆。这非常令人兴奋，因为这基本上是两个非常令人兴奋的事物的结合。但今天，我认为我们应该讲述战争的绝对开端以及德国对顽强的小比利时的猛烈进攻。因此，比利时人对列日英雄般的防御，布鲁塞尔的失陷，以及在盟军宣传中变得如此重要的议题，也就是用当时的术语来说，对比利时的蹂躏，德国对比利时平民的报复和暴行。
Were they real? Were they contrived? You know, what's the truth. That's what I was conveying with that opening because obviously as someone who is British, the impact of this on Britain is immense, isn't it? And kind of Steve, it's Britain for the war. So that's what I was doing. So any German listeners, I was kind of conveying the complexities of our shared history. And I think there are still a lot of people who would go along with the old idea put about, obviously, about Allied propaganda in the 1910s. And then by lots of historians, the idea that the Germans are almost uniquely responsible.
它们是真的吗？它们是捏造的吗？你知道，真相是什么。这就是我用那段开场白想要传达的，因为很显然，作为一个英国人，这对英国的影响是巨大的，不是吗？某种程度上，史蒂夫，正是英国促成了这场战争。所以我刚才做的是这个。因此，任何德国听众，我都在某种程度上传达我们共同历史的复杂性。我认为仍然有很多 人会认同过去那种关于20世纪10年代盟军宣传的旧观点。然后由许多历史学家提出，认为德国几乎负有唯一责任。
for the war. That it's a noble cause and that the Germans are the bad guys. And actually, I don't know where you stand on this, Tom, but it's not just propaganda because there are lots of very distinguished historians who've made that case, aren't there? Most notably a German, right? Fritz Fisher in the 1960s, who essentially looked at the plans for conquests that the German high command had the war aims, the war goals, and associated those war aims and goals and the behavior of the German troops in the invasion of Belgium with what then happened in the Second World War, kind of implied a correlation between the two, a line of dissent. Yeah, Fritz Fischer was writing in the 1960s, and he basically said, come on, Nazis
为了这场战争。这是一个崇高的事业，德国人是坏人。实际上，汤姆，我不知道你对这个问题怎么看，但这不仅仅是宣传，因为有许多非常杰出的历史学家都提出过这种观点，不是吗？最著名的就是德国人，对吧？弗里茨·费舍尔在20世纪60年代，他基本上研究了德国最高指挥部对征服的计划、战争目标，并将这些战争目标以及德军在入侵比利时的行为，与后来第二次世界大战中发生的事情联系起来，暗示了两者之间的某种关联，即一条继承脉络。是的，弗里茨·费舍尔在20世纪60年代写作，他基本上说过，得了吧，纳粹
have come from nowhere. There's a continuity between the Wilhelmine Empire and the Third Reich. And he dug out this bit of evidence, which was a, so the bloke that you were ventriloquising, the Chancellor, Tehrbalt, Bethmann, Holveg. In early September, he basically drafted this list of demands that just, Germany would want when they'd won the war. And they would annex Eastern France, Luxembourg, Belgium and Holland would become as kind of vassal client states. They'd take the Allies, African colonies. There would be a German customs union from the Baltic to the Mediterranean.
并不是凭空出现的。威廉帝国和第三帝国之间存在着连续性。他挖出了这样一条证据，也就是你刚才用腹语模仿的那个家伙，首相特奥巴尔德·贝特曼·霍尔维格。在9月上旬，他基本上起草了一份要求清单，仅仅是，德国在赢得战争后会想要的。他们将吞并法国东部、卢森堡、比利时和荷兰将成为某种附庸国。他们将夺取盟军在非洲的殖民地。将建立一个从波罗的海延伸到地中海的德国关税同盟。
So Neil Ferguson famously called this the Kaiser's European Union. And there are people to this day who say, well, this is the proof positive that Germany started the war, motivated by a kind of lust for conquest, born of their kind of insecurity and all their issues and whatnot. I don't agree with that. I think there are a lot of historians who don't agree with that. I think this is basically a wish list produced for discussion, produced after the war started as the German armies are approaching Paris. I think the Germans are actually much more anxious and much more reactive than most people allow. In other words, they're motivated by fear as much as they are by sort of aggression. But the two aren't mutually exclusive, are they? No. The aggression is often
因此尼尔·弗格森曾名其为“凯撒的欧盟”。至今仍有人说，这确凿地证明了德国发动了战争，其动机是对征服的渴望，这种渴望源于他们的某种不安全感以及各种问题等等。我不同意这种说法。我认为有很多历史学家也不同意这一点。我认为这基本上是一份为了讨论而炮制的愿望清单，是在战争爆发后、德国军队逼近巴黎时制作的。我认为德国人实际上比大多数人所承认的要焦虑得多、反应过敏得多。换句话说，他们的动机既源于恐惧，也源于某种侵略性。但这两者并不是互不排斥的，对吧？不。侵略性通常是
is there, of course. They're quite a militaristic society. But the aggression, I guess, is exacerbated, heightened by fear. You're more likely to lash out, as we will see when they enter Belgium, when they cross the Belgian border. But it's true for all the competence that all of them are motivated by fear, and the fear feeds into hatred, and the hatred then feeds into aggression. I totally agree with you. And if we remind ourselves how the Germans got to this point. So things have moved quite quickly. On the 28th of June, Franz Ferdinand was assassinated in Sarajevo. On the 5th of the 5th of the... July, the Kaiser and Betman Holveg gave the Austrians their blank check. Do what you like against
存在的，当然。他们是一个相当崇尚军国主义的社会。但侵略性，我猜，是被恐惧所加剧、激化的。正如我们稍后看到他们进入比利时、跨越比利时边境时那样，你更有可能发起猛烈抨击。但这适用于所有的参战国，他们所有人都是出于恐惧，而恐惧转化为仇恨，仇恨进而转化为侵略。我完全同意你的看法。如果我们回想一下德国人是如何走到这一步的。所以事情进展得相当快。6月28日，弗朗茨·费迪南德在萨拉热窝遇刺。7月……
Serbia to punish them. But then actually there's a hiatus of about 22 days where the Kaiser is off on that lovely cruise of his. Yeah, everyone's on holiday, aren't they? Betman Holvig's on holiday too, isn't he? I mean, the whole, basically everybody's on holiday. Most people go to spa hotels, but the Kaiser who loves it, as we know, loves a yachting shoe. He loves a fjord. Yeah, he does love a fjord. So he's gone off to, what, the sort of North Sea, hasn't he? He's gone to Norway on a yacht. He's gone to Norway. And he comes back on the 27th of July.
5日，凯撒和贝特曼·霍尔维格给了奥地利人他们的空白支票。对塞尔维亚采取任何你喜欢的行动来惩罚他们。但随后实际上有一个大约22天的真空期，凯撒去进行他那次愉快的巡航了。是的，每个人都在度假，不是吗？贝特曼·霍尔维格也在度假，对吧？我的意思是，整个，基本上每个人都在度假。大多数人去温泉酒店，但我们知道，热爱游艇巡游的凯撒，他最喜欢游艇巡游了。他喜欢峡湾。是的，他确实很喜欢峡湾。所以他去了，什么，北海，对吧？他坐着游艇去了挪威。他去了挪威。然后他在7月27日回来。
And he basically, to his surprise, he finds the situation is completely out of control. The Austrians have given Serbia an ultimatum that is designed to trigger a war. Even at this point, Bethmann-Holveg says, you know, war might not happen. And Kaiser then spends the next few days dreaming up elaborate weasers. So basically, having spent 20 years of his life, dream up elaborate weasers to, I don't know, invade Paraguay or something. Now his dream of elaborate weas is not to have the war that's actually going to happen. Anyway, in the 28th of July. a month after the shooting. Austria finally declares war on Serbia and begins the attack early
他基本上惊讶地发现，局势已经完全失控了。奥地利人向塞尔维亚发出了一份旨在引发战争的最后通牒。即便在此时，贝特曼·霍尔维格还说，你知道，战争可能不会发生。然后凯撒在接下来的几天里梦想着各种精心设计的诡计。基本上，在花了20年时间梦想着各种精心设计的诡计去，我不知道，入侵巴拉圭之类的地方之后。现在他梦想的精心设计的诡计竟然不是去打那场实际上就要爆发的战争。无论如何，在7月28日。在枪击事件发生一个月后。奥地利终于对塞尔维亚宣战，并在第二天清晨开始进攻
the next day and the next day the Russians really begin to mobilize in earnest. And this is the key point, isn't it? It is. So this is the point when German is military commanders enter the picture. And the key one who's going to play a big part in this series that we're doing is a guy called Helmut von Moltke the Younger. So his uncle von Malka the Elder had been the great victor of the Franco-Prussian War. And everybody thinks von Malka the Elder is absolutely brilliant, fantastic. And everybody basically has spent the last few years, Saint-Volmalka the younger.
第二天，俄国人真正开始全面动员。这就是关键点，不是吗？是的。所以这就是德国军事指挥官粉墨登场的时刻。将在我们制作的这个系列中扮演重要角色的关键人物是一个叫小赫尔穆特·冯·毛奇的人。他的叔叔老毛奇曾是普法战争的伟大胜利者。每个人都认为老毛奇绝对才华横溢、棒极了。基本上每个人过去几年都在说，圣毛奇是小毛奇。
You're not as good. Yeah, which plays on his mind because actually, like almost everybody in this story, it's clearly something in the water in the Edwardian period. He's extremely kind of melancholic and brooding, isn't he? He's a Christian scientist, which I think we talked about last time when he came up. Basically, that's that that Jesus was a scientist,
你没那么优秀。是的，这折磨着他的心智，因为实际上，就像这个故事里的几乎所有人一样，爱德华七世时代的水里显然有什么东西。他极其忧郁且沉思，不是吗？他是一个基督教科学派信徒，我想我们上次提到他时谈到过这一点。基本上，那是……耶稣是一位科学家，
and science is great, is that right? I'm not entirely sure. I'm not entirely sure. When we do a big series on Christian science, we'll pretend that we knew you all along. He plays the cello, which I think is not a warlike thing to do. He's obsessed with the occult and with spiritualism. He's a follower of this lady called Madame Blavatsky. Everyone is.
而科学很伟大，是这样吗？我不太确定。我不太确定。当我们做一个关于基督教科学派的大型系列时，我们会假装我们一直都了解你。他拉大提琴，我认为这不是一件好战的事情。他痴迷于神秘主义和唯心主义。他是这个叫布拉瓦茨基夫人的女性的追随者。每个人都这样。
They're all into this kind of mad stuff. I was just thinking about this. His first name is Helmut. And that's a little bit like helmet. Okay. Where are you going with this? Well, so the German helmets with the spikes on. I think in the kind of the British imagination, that is the.
他们都对这种疯狂的东西感兴趣。我刚才在想这个。他的名字叫赫尔穆特（Helmut）。这听起来有点像头盔（helmet）。好吧。你想表达什么？好吧，德国人戴的那种带尖顶的头盔。我认为在英国人的想象中，那是。
embodiment of Prussian militarism. It is. Completely it is. And also he has one of those moustaches where the ends turn up. One thing to say, if people want to picture what the Germans look like and the French and the British, every German has a moustache with the, I think, the ends turn up. The French all have massive white warrous moustaches and the British all have kind of reserved, clipped moustaches.
普鲁士军国主义的化身。确实是。完全是的。而且他留着那种两端向上翘起的胡子。有一点要说，如果人们想想象德国人、法国人和英国人的长相，每个德国人都留着两端向上翘起的胡子。法国人都留着巨大的白色大胡子，而英国人则留着那种矜持、修剪整齐的胡子。
I thought with this first episode there were some excellent moustaches. But you see, I know what's coming and you don't know what's coming to. Tom, because I haven't yet shared the notes. So in the later episodes of this series, when the Russians enter the picture, it's a very different and much superior moustache game. There's a guy called Renencamp and Alexei Brusilov, and they have moustaches that basically would not fit on the screen. But that proves my point.
我觉得第一集里有一些非常棒的胡子。但你看，我知道接下来会发生什么，而汤姆你还不知道接下来会发生什么。汤姆，因为我还没分享笔记。所以在这个系列的后面几集里，当俄国人登场时，那是一个非常不同且水平高得多的胡子局。有个叫雷宁坎普和阿列克谢·勃鲁西洛夫的人，他们的胡子根本塞不下屏幕。但这就证明了我的观点。
So if you want to imagine the Russians, massive moustaches. I mean, the moustaches essentially define the competent nations. That's the key thing. And so Mulk, he has this moustache. And because his name's helmet, also subliminally, it conjured up a sense of him wearing a spike on his helmet. That's what's going on in the head of British listeners, I think. Well, certainly what's going on your head. I mean, whether it's going on anyone else has said, I do not know.
所以如果你想想象俄国人，巨大的胡子。我的意思是，胡子基本上定义了各个参战国。这才是关键所在。所以毛奇留着这种胡子。而且因为他的名字叫“头盔”，潜意识里，这也让人联想起他头盔上戴着个尖顶。英国听众脑子里想的就是这个，我想。好吧，当然是你脑子里想的。至于其他人脑子里是不是这么想的，我可不知道。
Let's go back to Vonmulke. Like a lot of bit Germans of his class, he is absolutely obsessed with this idea of the inevitable war between Teuton and Slav. So they love talking like this in 1910s, Germany. And they're very worried that the Teutons will lose because there are so many Slavs and not enough of them. And so actually, Von Mouker has spent. the last few years saying, well, I hope we have this war quite soon because otherwise we'll probably lose. There are just so many Russians. And also, they're haunted by history, aren't they? And the defeat of the Teutonic Knights. They are. We will come to that.
让我们回到冯·毛奇。和许多他那个阶层的德国人一样，他绝对痴迷于条顿人与斯拉夫人之间不可避免的战争这个想法。所以他们在1910年代的德国非常喜欢这样谈论。他们非常担心条顿人会失败，因为斯拉夫人太多了而他们不够多。所以实际上，冯·毛奇花时间
We will come to that. Very exciting. My history repeat itself will be reversed. We will see. We will see. But actually, von Molka, once the crisis slows up, he doesn't really urge the Kaiser into war. He's been on holiday, of course, during July. In a spa? In a spa hotel, having a rest cure because he's like a lot of these people, he's really ill. So half of these generals actually go into the war, like virtually at death's door. And he has already said to the Kaiser, war will be a long wearisome struggle. It will utterly exhaust our own people, even if we're victorious. Oh, that's optimistic.
在过去的几年里说，好吧，我希望我们很快能打这场仗，否则我们可能会输。俄国人实在太多了。而且，他们也被历史所困扰，不是吗？还有条顿骑士团的失败。是的。我们会谈到这一点的。
Fighting talk there. At the end of July with the war just hours away, he says to the Kaiser, I still think we can win, but just so you know, the war could annihilate for decades the civilization of almost all Europe. Oh, brilliant. Well, I look forward to that. As we get to the very end of July, Malka realizes that the clock is ticking. And this sense of urgency is massively important to understanding what happens in Belgium. And this, like Malka's sort of brooding melancholy, reflects the broader strategic position that faces the central powers. So he is running the most modern, the most formidable military machine in the world. However, there are good grounds for fearing a conflagration, that they might not win. Because if you're fighting Russia, Russia's population and therefore manpower is a third bigger than Germany's and Austria-Hungaries combined. And if the Russians are joined by France, Britain and by Belgium, the so-called Entente will have almost 280 million people and the central powers only 120 million. And Dominic also, of course, Russia and France
我们会谈到这一点的。非常令人兴奋。历史会重演将被颠倒。我们会看到的。我们会看到的。但实际上，一旦危机加剧，冯·毛奇并没有真正敦促凯撒开战。当然，他在7月份一直在度假。在温泉疗养地？在温泉酒店里进行静养疗法，因为他和许多这样的人一样，身体真的很糟糕。所以实际上这些将军有一半人几乎是拖着病体走向战争的。他已经对凯撒说过，战争将是一场漫长而疲惫的斗争。它将彻底榨干我们自己的人民，即使我们取得胜利。哦，这还真乐观。
are on either flank of Germany. So that's the other huge anxiety, isn't it? That they might be crushed between these two sides. The sense of being encircled, I think, is massively important to understanding the German mentality, above all. Economically, so you take those two powers on the flanks. France and Russia, their combined GDP, is much bigger than Germany's and Austria's. And they have far more soldiers. Six million soldiers, the Entente have.
那边是好战的言论。在7月底，随着战争仅剩数小时之遥，他对凯撒说，我依然认为我们能赢，但为了让你知道，这场战争可能会让几乎整个欧洲的文明毁灭数十年。哦，太棒了。好吧，我拭目以待。当我们接近7月底时，毛奇意识到时间所剩无几了。这种紧迫感对于理解比利时发生的事情至关重要。这一点，就像毛奇那种深沉的忧郁一样，反映了同盟国所面临的更广泛的战略地位。因此，他掌控着世界上最现代、最强大的军事机器。然而，有充分的理由担心会爆发全面冲突，他们可能不会赢。因为如果你在与俄国作战，俄国的人口以及因此的人力资源比德国和奥匈帝国的总和还要多三分之一。如果俄国人与法国、英国和比利时联合起来，所谓的协约国将拥有近2.8亿人口，而同盟国只有1.2亿。而且多米尼克，当然还有俄国和法国
The central powers, less than three and a half million. So if you're von Moltke, sitting in your spa, thinking about theosophy and the occult, and you'll also make a little bit of time to think about this war. You know that in a long war it'll be really hard for you to win, that all the cards are in the Entente's hands. And Dominant, just to ask, of course they're aware of the massive manpower that Russia has, but they are also presumably fully aware that actually France is an even more militarized society than Germany, isn't it? It is a formidable opponent, but you have to choose one of these opponents to go for first.
位于德国的两翼。所以这是另一个巨大的焦虑，不是吗？他们可能会被这两方夹击。被包围的感觉，我认为对于理解德国人的心态至关重要，高于一切。从经济上讲，如果你把两翼的那两个强国算上。法国和俄国，它们的综合GDP比德国和奥地利大得多。而且它们拥有多得多的士兵。协约国拥有六百万士兵。
Their only realistic possibility of victory is to start to knock their enemies out quickly. before the Entente's kind of underlying advantages can be made to tell. So when Von Malka took over as the Chief of Staff in 1906, he inherited something called the Schlieffen Plan. Anyone who's done this for GCSE or A-Level in England will know about this. Now, this doesn't mean that Germany was planning a war, as sometimes people think. Basically, all nations had contingency plans. The French had a plan called Plont de Set, which we'll come to next time.
同盟国则不到三百五十万。所以如果你是冯·毛奇，坐在你的温泉疗养地里，思考着神智学和神秘主义，你也会抽出一点时间来思考这场战争。你知道，在长期战争中你将很难获胜，所有的王牌都掌握在协约国手中。多米尼克，顺便问一句，当然他们意识到俄国拥有庞大的人力，但他们大概也完全清楚，实际上法国是一个比德国还要军国主义化的社会，不是吗？它是一个强大的对手，但你必须首先选择其中一个对手进行打击。
But this Schlefen plan, elaborated by Malker's predecessor, Graf Alfred von Schlefen, they've revised it and revised it. And military historians basically spend their entire careers arguing about this plan, but to boil it down and make it very simple. It's all about the Battle of Caney, isn't it? It is a muddled a little bit on the Battle of Cannae. Because he was obsessed by it, encircling and wiping out superior enemies. So the premise of it is, look, we can't win a long war.
他们唯一现实的胜利可能性就是迅速击溃敌人。在协约国潜在优势发挥作用之前。因此，当冯·毛奇于1906年接任总参谋长时，他继承了一种名为“施里芬计划”的东西。在英国参加过普通中等教育证书（GCSE）或高级水平考试（A-Level）的人都会知道这一点。这并不意味着德国在策划一场战争，正如人们有时认为的那样。基本上所有国家都有应急计划。法国人有一个名为“17号计划”的计划，我们下次会讨论。
If we have a long war, there will probably be an economic collapse in a revolution. ocean when they're not wrong. So the priority is to knock one enemy out before turning on the other one. Now we wouldn't be able to knock the Russians out quickly because their army is inferior, but they have so many men. So we basically have to take on the French first. Now we cannot do what we did in 187071. We can't just go across the Franco-German border because the French have built these swanky new fortresses, Verdun, Nancy, Belfour, places like this that stand in the way and they will slow us down. So we have to find another way into France, and that is through Belgium.
但这个施里芬计划，由毛奇的前任小阿尔弗雷德·冯·施里芬精心制定，他们一改再改。军事史学家基本上花了一整职业生涯来争论这个计划，但如果把它归纳并简化。这全关乎坎尼战役，不是吗？它在坎尼战役上有点混乱。因为他对此着迷，即包围和消灭优势敌人。所以它的前提是，听着，我们无法赢得一场长期战争。
And the brilliant thing about Belgium is that has a very dense railway network, so we'll be able to move our troops really quickly. And Dominic, just to ask, the French, it never crosses their mind the Germans might do this, and so they don't build forts along the frontier with Belgium. I think they, it's, I mean, they're not idiots, right? It's not like they think it's impossible the Germans could go through Belgium, but their priority is the forts along their own border, I guess. And building forts along the Belgian border would,
如果我们打一场长期战争，很可能会发生经济崩溃和革命。潮流当他们并没有错。因此，当务之急是在转向另一个敌人之前先击溃一个敌人。现在，我们无法迅速击溃俄国人，因为他们的军队虽劣势，但他们人太多了。所以我们基本上必须先对付法国人。现在我们不能像1870-71年那样做了。我们不能直接穿过法德边境，因为法国人建造了这些时髦的新堡垒，凡尔登、南锡、贝尔福，这些地方挡在路上，它们会拖慢我们的速度。所以我们必须找到另一条进入法国的通道，那就是通过比利时。
seem a bit weird because it would look as if you're protecting yourselves against an invasion by the Belgians, which seems very implausible. It might be a threat to French self-esteem, I suppose. Yeah, exactly. It would be like suddenly England decided to build loads of forts on the border with Wales. Well, it's good enough for offer. Right. Yes, that's true. Anyway, once you've gone through Belgium, basically the plan is that the left wing of your
而比利时的妙处在于它拥有非常密集的铁路网，所以我们能够非常迅速地移动我们的军队。多米尼克，顺便问一下，法国人从未想过德国人会这么做，所以他们没有在与比利时的边境沿线修建堡垒吗？我想他们，这，我的意思是，他们不是白痴，对吧？并不是说他们认为德国人穿过比利时是不可能的，但他们的首要任务是我猜自己边境沿线的堡垒。在比利时边境沿线修建堡垒会
army, so that's the southernmost wing, will pin the French against their own border, against these fortresses. And meanwhile, the northernmost, the right wing bit of the journey. German army will go all the way around Paris and encircle the French capital. That way, we'll crush their army against the frontier, we'll encircle their capital, France will be knocked out, and then we'll use the railways to move all the troops east as quickly as possible to the borderlands of East Prussia and Galicia, where hopefully our Austro-Hungarian allies will have kept the Russians at bay.
显得有点奇怪，因为这看起来就像是在防范比利时的入侵，这显得很不合情理。我想，这可能会对法国人的自尊心构成威胁。是的，完全如此。这就好比英国人突然决定在与威尔士的边境上修建大量堡垒。嗯，对奥法（Offa）来说这就足够了。对。是的，确实如此。无论如何，一旦你穿过了比利时，基本上计划是你们军队的左翼，
We'll see how the Austro-Hungarians get on later in this series. Now, we have to do all this in six weeks. We have six weeks to do all this before the Russians start to break through in the East. And if we fall behind, we'll be into that war of attrition that we don't want and we could well lose. And also, presumably, if the Russians break through in the East, they can capture Berlin. They can go all the way into Germany. They can drive into Germany. They can drive into Central of Austria, Hungary. So the risk is that the Germans might capture Paris and the Russians might capture Berlin. I suppose so. That would be a twist, wouldn't it? This is a massively risky idea. So even if the Germans concentrate their forces in the West, they will. still have fewer divisions than the French, the British and the Belgians put together. But that's where the canny thing comes in, right? That you use the size of your enemy's forces against them. Exactly.
也就是最南端的侧翼，将把法军钉死在他们自己的边境上，紧贴着这些堡垒。与此同时，最北端，也就是行军的右翼。德军将绕过巴黎一整圈，包围法国首都。通过这种方式，我们将把他们的军队压碎在边境上，包围他们的首都，法国将被击溃，然后我们将利用铁路尽快将所有军队向东调往东普鲁士和加利西亚的边境地区，希望到那时我们的奥匈帝国盟友已经将俄国人阻挡在外。
They're lumbering and unwieldy, but you're moving swiftly. Now, there's a brilliant book on Germany and Austria and the Central Powers in the First War called Ring of Steel by a British historical Alexander Watson. As he points out, this is, quote, a breathtakingly audacious and full-hardy aspiration. Because the French are not nothing. The French have one of Europe's most modern and biggest armed forces. How are you going to knock them out so quickly? And the very fact that von Malka is considering such a scheme is a sign actually of
我们将在本系列的后面部分看看奥匈帝国的情况如何。现在，我们必须在六周内完成这一切。我们在俄国人开始在东方突破之前有六周时间来完成这一切。如果我们落后了，我们将陷入那场我们不想要且很可能会输掉的消耗战。而且，大概如果俄国人在东方突破，他们可以攻占柏林。他们可以一直打进德国。他们可以冲进德国。他们可以冲进中奥匈帝国。因此，风险在于德国人可能会攻占巴黎，而俄国人可能会攻占柏林。我想是这样的。那将是一个转折，不是吗？这是一个风险极大的想法。因此，即使德国人将兵力集中在西部，他们
Germany's underlying strategic weakness. And that's actually one reason why I think, I don't think the Germans are motivated by lust for conquest and aggression in this war because they're up against it from the very, very beginning. They have to consider such a mad gamble. But speed underlies everything. If you can't do it in six weeks, you're in real trouble. So if we go back to the summer of 1914, by the last two days of July, Von Malker is studying all his reports with a massive sense of kind of panic.
的师数仍然比法军、英军和比利时军加起来还要少。但这就是坎尼战役的巧妙之处切入的地方，对吧？你利用敌人兵力的规模来对付他们自己。没错。他们笨重而难驾驭，但你行动迅速。现在，有一本关于第一次世界大战中的德国、奥地利和同盟国的精彩著作，书名叫《钢铁之环》，作者是英国历史学家亚历山大·沃森。正如他所指出的，这是一个“令人窒息的大胆且鲁莽的抱负”。因为法国并非无名之辈。法国拥有欧洲最现代、规模最大的武装力量之一。你打算怎么这么快就把他们击溃？冯·毛奇正在考虑这样一个方案，这本身就是
The Russians are mobilising. The Belgians are calling up their reserves. The Belgians are fortifying Lijj, which is not just the key point in their eastern defences, but is their major railway hub. And von Malka knows that taking liege quickly is central to his battle pan. Hour by hour, he's thinking, God, it's slipping away. it hasn't even started. So it's at this point that he and the Prussian War Minister, Eric von Falkenheim, who is a person again will be hearing from in this series. That's a great name. The thing about the Germans is they have the names that Richard Wagner would have given them.
德国潜在战略疲软的一个迹象。这也是为什么我认为，我不认为德国人在这场战争中是出于对征服和侵略的渴望，因为他们从一开始就处于劣势。他们不得不考虑这样一场疯狂的赌博。但速度是一切的基础。如果你在六周内做不到，你就会有大麻烦。因此，如果我们回到1914年的夏天，到了7最后两天，冯·毛奇正以一种巨大的恐慌感研究着他所有的报告。
Yeah, but again, it's a falcon. I mean, it's like a falcon waiting to sweep down. I think the names are cundering up all kinds of images. So they say to the Kaiser, okay, right, the war's going to happen and we've got to really crack on that. Stop messing around. So they proclaim a state of imminent war on the 31st of July. They send their ultimatums to Russia and to France. And then the next day, this amazing scene
俄国人在动员。比利时人在征召预备役。比利时人正在加固列日，列日不仅是他们东部防线的关键点，也是他们主要的铁路枢纽。冯·毛奇知道迅速攻克列日是其作战计划的核心。每时每刻他都在想，天哪，机会正在溜走。甚至还没开始呢。正是在这个时候，他和普鲁士战争大臣埃里希·冯·法金汉（Eric von Falkenheim，注：即埃里希·von·法金汉），也就是我们在这个系列中会再次听到的人物。这是一个很棒的名字。德国人的特点是他们拥有理查德·瓦格纳会给他们的那种名字。
that I think we talked about last time, Wilhelm, driving down the Unter de Linden Avenue in the sort of uniform of a cavalryman with his helmet on.
是的，但再次强调，这是一只猎鹰（Falcon）。我的意思是，这就像一只等待俯冲的猎鹰。我认为这些名字唤起了各种各样的形象。所以他们对凯撒说，好吧，对了，战争就要发生了，我们得加把劲了。别再瞎胡闹了。因此他们在7月31日宣布进入迫近战争状态。他们向俄国和法国发出最后通牒。然后在第二天，这个惊人的场景
He goes into the Royal Palace. He signs the mobilisation order brilliantly at a table hewn from the timbers of Nelson's victory that was a gift from the British. They've all got tears in their eyes. They're shaking hands.
我想我们上次谈到过，威廉身穿骑兵制服，戴着头盔，驾驶着汽车沿着林荫大道（Unter den Linden）驶去。
There's a crowd outside singing Frederick the Great Era hymns. So a hymn called Now Thank We All Our God, which is a Lutheran hymn that Frederick the great soldiers had sung after a victory in the 18th century. And then the Kaiser, he goes out on the balcony and he gives this great speech, you know. Can I do it? Go on, go on, go on, go on. In the battle now lying ahead of us, I no longer see any political parties.
他走进皇宫。他在一张由纳尔逊号“胜利”号战舰的木材凿成的桌子上漂亮地签署了动员令，那是英国人送的礼物。他们所有人都热泪盈眶。他们紧紧握手。
I see only Germans. All that matters now is that we're going. We stand together like brothers, and God will help the German sword to victory. That's how he spoke. And I think he really means this. He does. It feels very impassioned. Yeah, I think it's important for listeners to get that into their heads that the Germans genuinely think that the war has been forced upon them.
外面聚集着人群，高唱着腓特烈大帝时期的赞美诗。一首名为《现在感谢我们所有的上帝》（Now Thank We All Our God）的赞美诗，这是一首路德宗赞美诗，腓特烈大帝的士兵在18世纪的一次胜利后曾唱过这首歌。然后凯撒走到阳台上，发表了这篇伟大的演讲，你知道的。我能模仿吗？来吧，来吧，来吧，来吧。在摆在我们面前的这场战斗中，我不再看到任何政党。
There's no question in their minds that God is on their side. And that explains why, for example, the biggest party, not just in Germany, actually, but in Europe, which is the Social Democratic Party, a left-wing anti-militarist party votes unanimously to fund the war, to give them war credits, and they agree they will not criticise the German government for the whole of the war.
我只看到德国人。现在唯一重要的是我们正在前进。我们像兄弟一样站在一起，上帝会帮助德国之剑取得胜利。这就是他说话的方式。我想他是真心实意的。他是认真的。这感觉非常充满激情。是的，我认为让听众把这一点印在脑子里是很重要的，即德国人真诚地认为战争是被强加给他们的。
The trade unions promise they won't strike for the whole of the war, and this is because they really think Germany has been very hard done by, and this is a noble cause. But it also reflects, I think, a sense of seriousness. They know that the troops will not be home by Christmas. Do they?
他们坚信上帝站在他们这一边。这就解释了为什么，例如，不仅在德国，实际上在全欧洲最大的政党——社会民主党，一个左翼反军国主义政党，会一致投票资助战争，向他们提供战争信贷，并且他们同意在整个战争期间不批评德国政府。
But the Schlieffen plan requires France to be knocked out within six weeks and then are they not hoping for a rapid victory? Well, here's the thing. I think they're hoping for a rapid victory but fearing they might not get it against France. But once they've beaten France in six weeks, if they manage to pull that off, they're then up against the Russians. And one of the sort of premises of their plan is the idea that the Russians will be very, very hard to beat. because of their manpower, because they know, you know, you go east and you get lost like Charles the 12th or like Napoleon in the great vastness of Russia. Best case scenario, you can probably do that in another six months, a year. You know, who knows how long it takes? They are
工会承诺在整个战争期间不罢工，这是因为他们真的认为德国受到了很不公正的待遇，这是一场崇高的事业。但这也反映出了一种严肃的态度。他们知道军队不会在圣诞节前回家。他们知道吗？
expecting a water lasts that long. Of course. And the newspapers in Germany, you know, the Frankfurt Zeitum, over everything hangs at great gravity in their quiet rooms. Wives and young women sit nursing a great fear of terrible things of what may be to come. That doesn't sound to me like the journalism of a country that thinks this will be done and dusted really quickly like the Franco-Prussian War and we'll all be having, you know, we'll be celebrating on the 25th of December. That says to me they know that they're an existential struggle of fight for their lives. In a later episode, we'll talk a little bit about why they didn't stop.
但施里芬计划要求在六周内击溃法国，难道他们不希望取得迅速的胜利吗？事情是这样的。我认为他们希望取得迅速胜利，但又担心对法国可能无法做到这一点。但一旦他们在六周内击败了法国，如果他们成功做到了这一点，他们接下来就要面对俄国人。而他们计划的前提之一就是认为俄国人将非常非常难以击败。因为他们的人力，因为你知道，你向东进发，就会像查理十二世或拿破仑一样在俄罗斯广袤的土地上迷失。在最佳情况下，你可能还需要六个月到一年的时间才能做到这一点。你知道，谁知道要花多长时间？他们
As in as the war becomes a stalemate, why don't people stop fighting? And I think one reason they don't stop fighting is they think, rightly, the survival of our entire society depends on winning this war. And if we lose it, you know, we're finished. And so that's why the famous phrase in that speech that the Kaiser gives is that he no longer sees any political parties, he sees only Germans. That becomes kind of emblematic of the German sense of an entire nation at war, right? Yes, absolutely. It does. Absolutely. But if you're a German and you think, well, we're absolutely the good guys in this. You know, there's no doubt whatsoever that we're the plucky underdogs.
期待着一场持续那么久的战争。当然。德国的报纸，你知道，《法兰克福报》（Frankfurter Zeitung），在他们宁静的房间里，一切都悬挂着巨大的严肃氛围。妻子和年轻女性坐着，怀着对未来可怕之事的巨大恐惧。这听起来不像是一个国家的 journalism，它认为这将像普法战争那样迅速搞定，然后我们都会在12月25日举杯庆祝。这告诉我，他们知道这是一场为生存而战的生死决斗。在后面的剧集中，我们会稍微谈谈为什么他们没有停下来。
The one problem you have is that you are clearly breaking international law with your plan to go through Belgium. Because Belgium, to remind people from last time, Belgium's a buffer state created largely by the British, actually, after the revolution of 1830 against the Netherlands, all the great powers that signed treaties to guarantee its independence and its neutrality, first in 1830. 39 and then in 1870 and during the Franco-Prussian war, Belgium had been neutral and independent. And if the Germans go into Belgium and if the Belgians appeal for help, then Britain is legally bound to offer help. They're what form that help will take is ambiguous and undefined. So the British, just to quickly glance across the channel, they have been debating
就像战争陷入僵局时一样，为什么人们不停止战斗呢？我认为他们不停止战斗的一个原因是他们正确地认为，我们整个社会的生存取决于赢得这场战争。如果我们输了，你知道，我们就完了。所以这就是凯撒演讲中那句名言的由来，即他不再看到任何政党，他只看到德国人。这成为了整个国家处于战争状态的德国意识的象征，对吗？是的，绝对是的。确实如此。但如果你是一个德国人，并且你认为，好吧，我们绝对是这其中的好人。你知道，毫无疑问我们是顽强的弱者。
this for the last few days. They're still very undecided. We talked last time about how in the cabinet meetings, some of the British ministers have said, look, if the Germans just go through a little bit of Belgium using the railway, and they don't cause any damage and stuff, it's not grounds for us to fight. Churchill, incredibly bellicose in this period, actually said at one point to his cabinet colleagues, I don't see why we should come in if they go only a little way into Belgium. In other words, you know, maybe we can still stay out. The bad thing about all this is such a diplomatic fog. Nobody knows exactly what anybody else is thinking. And the Germans, don't know what the British are thinking. And so they end up making a terrible mistake, arguably, I would say the biggest diplomatic mistake of modern history. But of course, the French do know that if the British are to enter the war, it's really vital that the Germans are seen to be the bad guys, the guys who've infringed Belgian neutrality. And so they kind of issue military dictates, don't they, that on no account are French troops to enter Belgium, that no French planes are to go enter Belgian airspace or anything like that. It's really, really, you know,
你遇到的一个问题是，你的计划是通过比利时，这显然违反了国际法。因为比利时，提醒大家上次所说的话，比利时是一个缓冲区，主要由英国人在1830年反对荷兰的革命后建立，所有签署条约的大国都保证其独立性和中立性，首先是在1830年。39年，然后在1870年以及普法战争期间，比利时一直保持中立和独立。如果德国人进入比利时，如果比利时人呼吁援助，那么英国就合法地有义务提供援助。这种援助将采取何种形式是模棱两可、未定义的。所以英国人，迅速看一眼海峡对岸，他们一直在辩论
vital to France's interests that Germany do this. Exactly. And the French refrain from attacking Germany, from attacking the Germans, they want the Germans to be seen as the aggressors. And so on the evening of Sunday the 2nd of August, the Germans make this cataclysmic mistake. At 7 o'clock, their ambassador gave the Belgians an ultimatum. He said, we want our armies to have safe passage on your railway system. We want to take over your border fortresses at Liege and Namur. We're very sorry about this.
这在过去几天里。他们仍然非常犹豫不决。我们上次讨论过，在内阁会议上，一些英国大臣曾说，听着，如果德国人只是利用铁路穿过一小部分比利时，并且没有造成任何破坏之类的事情，这不足以成为我们参战的理由。丘吉尔在这个时期极其好战，甚至一度对内阁同僚说，我看不出如果他们只是稍微进入一点比利时，我们为什么要卷入。换句话说，你知道，也许我们仍然可以置身事外。所有这一切糟糕的地方在于存在着如此深厚的外交迷雾。没有人确切知道其他人脑子里在想什么。德国人
We will get out as quickly as possible. We'll compensate you for any damage. We'll also pay for our own kind of board and lodging. So don't worry about that. Did no one ever think they could just buy tickets? Can you buy a ticket for like a million men? I don't know. Is that possible?
不知道英国人在想什么。所以他们最终犯了一个可怕的错误，可以说，我认为这是现代史上最大的外交错误。但当然，法国人确实知道，如果英国要参战，至关重要的是让德国人被视为坏人，即侵犯比利时中立性的人。所以他们会发布某种军事指令，不是吗？即在任何情况下法国军队都不得进入比利时，任何法国飞机都不得进入比利时领空之类的事情。这真的，真的，你知道，
Get a discount. It'll be a very amusing conversation at the counter. I want to bring a few horses as well. But then the Germans saying this alternative, we'll compensate you, but however, if you stand in our way, we will crush you. And you've got 12 hours to make up your minds. Now, the mad thing is they could just have gone through the south of Belgium. I mean, it would have been tricky, and maybe militarily it would have been very difficult.
对法国的利益至关重要，即德国必须这样做。完全正确。法国人克制自己不进攻德国，不进攻德国人，他们希望德国人被视为侵略者。因此，在8月2日星期日的傍晚，德国人犯下了这个灾难性的错误。7点钟，他们的驻外大使向比利时人递交了一份最后通牒。他说，我们希望我们的军队在你们的铁路系统上有安全通道。我们希望接管你们在列日和那慕尔的边境堡垒。对此我们非常抱歉。
But their foreign office, the German foreign office had said, we think that persuading the Belgians, basically bullying the Belgians into agreeing, is the only way to be sure the British won't intervene. However, this gamble completely backfires because even as nightfall comes, Belgium's King Albert, Albert, has already made up his mind. And at 7 o'clock the next morning, Belgium rejects the ultimatum. The irony is that to the hawks in London who wanted to join the war, Herbert Henry Asgwreth and Edward Gray, who we talked about in the last series, this is the perfect issue. It's the perfect Kazas Beli to rally Liberal Party opinion.
我们会尽快撤出。我们会赔偿你们造成的任何损失。我们还将支付我们自己的食宿费用。所以不要担心这个。难道从来没有人想过他们可以买票吗？你能为比如一百万人买票吗？我不知道。这可能吗？
So when Edward Gray spoke to the Commons, he made this huge deal about plucky little Belgium. They just want to be left alone and get on with exploiting the people of the Congo. No, that's, yeah, poor Belgium. His pitch is literally liberal interventionism. Literally liberal interventionism. So even before the Germans have fired their first shot, they've handed the British and their opponents, a most amazing propaganda weapon,
所以当爱德华·格雷在下议院发言时，他大肆宣扬勇敢的小比利时。他们只是想独自安宁，继续剥削刚果人民。不，那是，是的，可怜的比利时。他的论调简直就是自由主义干涉主义。简直就是自由主义干涉主义。因此，甚至在德国人开第一枪之前，他们就已经把英国人及其对手送上了一个最惊人的宣传武器，
breaking international law, all of this kind of thing. And the next morning the British duly issued their ultimatum. It's not true that the Germans weren't aware of this. They were very aware of it. So Beethoven-Holweg, when he spoke to the Reichstag, he said, listen, I completely understand why the Belgians, and Luxembourg as well. Nobody even mentions Lexenberg in this story,
违反国际法，诸如此类的事情。第二天早上，英国人理所当然地发出了最后通牒。说德国人对此一无所知是不真实的。他们非常清楚这一点。因此，贝特曼-霍尔维格在对帝国议会讲话时说，听着，我完全理解为什么比利时人，还有卢森堡也是如此。在这个故事里甚至没有人提到卢森堡，
poor of Luxembourg. We completely understand why they're aggrieved, that we're invading them, but we will make good the wrong we're doing as soon as we've attained our military objectives. When you're as imperiled as we are, fighting for everything we hold there, you can only think of how you'll cut your way out.
可怜的卢森堡。我们完全理解他们对我们入侵感到不满，但只要我们一旦达到军事目标，我们就会弥补我们所犯下的错误。当你处于我们这样的危急关头，为我们所珍视的一切而战时，你只能考虑如何杀出一条血路。
He's actually furious, though, in private, that the British are using this as a pretext. He has this huge argument with the British ambassador, who's called Goschen. That's a very German name, isn't it? I know, everyone's got the wrong name. Because this was a feature of the diplomatic exchanges, is that the Germans all had French.
然而，私底下他其实非常愤怒，因为英国人把这当成借口。他和英国大使大吵了一架，大使名叫戈申。这是一个非常德国的名字，不是吗？我知道，每个人都顶着错误的名字。因为这是外交交流的一个特点，那就是德国人都有法国名字，
names and the French all had German names and so on. And the generals are just as bad, right? When we get to General von Renenkamp, he's Russian. Yeah, exactly. And of course, a field marshal French. Yes, who hates the French. Who hates the French more than anybody. So anyway, the ambassador and Bethven-Holvig had an argument. And Bethvenorovic said to him, you are fighting just for a scrap of paper. Yeah, it's another German gaffe, because yet again, the British turn it into a great propaganda weapon. It features very heavily on posters. You can Google them, and you can see the references to the scrap of paper, although not as much as a gift as what the Germans get up to in the second half of this episode, because in Belgium
而法国人都有德国名字，诸如此类。将军们也同样糟糕，对吧？当我们谈到雷宁坎普将军时，他是俄罗斯人。是的，完全正确。当然，还有法国元帅。是的，他恨法国人。比任何人都更恨法国人。不管怎样，大使和贝特曼-霍尔维格争吵了起来。贝特曼-霍尔维格对他说，你们居然为了一张废纸而战。是的，这是另一个德国人的失误，因为英国人再次将其变成了伟大的宣传武器。它在海报上占据了极其重要的位置。你可以在谷歌上搜索，看看那些关于“废纸”的引用，尽管这远不如德国人在本集后半部分所搞出的动静那么具有话题性，因为在比利时
itself, the pace has quickened. At 8 o'clock that morning, so we are on the 3rd of August, Monday the 3rd of August 1914, the first German units crossed the Belgian border. And at midday, King Albert formally appealed to Britain as the guarantor of Belgian independence. And then he got on his horse. He's wearing full uniform. He leads this procession, including his wife and his 12-year-old son, who's dressed in a sailor suit, through the centre of Brussels. There are huge crowds of people cheering, some weeping, waving Belgian flags, the kind of trickular of Belgium. And he leads his family into the Belgian Parliament. And truly, it's an amazing scene. The deputies are all on their feet. They're chanting and shouting,
本身，节奏加快了。那天早上8点，也就是8月3日，1914年8月3日星期一，第一支德国部队越过了比利时边境。中午时分，阿尔贝国王正式向作为比利时独立担保人的英国发出呼吁。然后他上了马。他身穿全套制服。他率领着包括他的妻子和12岁、身穿水手服的儿子在内的游行队伍，穿过了布鲁塞尔市中心。现场有成群结队的群众在欢呼，有些人流着泪，挥舞着比利时国旗，那是比利时的三色旗。他带领家人走进了比利时议会。老实说，这是一个令人惊叹的场景。议员们全体起立。他们高呼着呐喊着，
live Le Croix, Vive la Belchique. And he goes up to the soot of the Rostrum and he says, not since 1830 has our country faced such a grave peril. The integrity of our homeland is under threat. Their task will be hard, but we stand prepared for the greatest sacrifices. And then he looks out and he says, gentlemen, are you determined at any cost to preserve the sacred heritage of our forefathers? And as a man, they get to their feet and they're all shouting, we, we, we, find words, Dominic, but when you have the mightest army of the world has ever seen preparing to cross your frontier, are words enough? And what horrors may lie in wait for the people of Belgium who we are legally obliged to describe at this point as plucky. We'll find out after the
万岁，比利时万岁。他走到演讲台前说，自1830年以来，我们的国家从未面临过如此严重的危机。我们祖国的完整正受到威胁。他们的任务将是艰巨的，但我们已准备好做出最大的牺牲。然后他环视四周说道，先生们，你们是否决心不惜一切代价捍卫我们祖先的神圣遗产？全场人们齐刷刷地站了起来，高喊着，愿意，愿意，愿意。言辞是苍白的，多米尼克，但是当世界上从未见过的最强大军队准备跨越你们的国界时，言辞够用吗？对于比利时人民来说，又会有怎样的恐怖在等待着他们？在这个节点上，我们在法律上有义务将他们描述为“勇敢的”。我们在休息之后
break. This episode is brought to you by Sega and Creative Assembly. To celebrate 25 years of creating award-winning video games, Total War, Rome 2 and Total War Rome Remastered will be on sale on Steam. Get Rome remastered at 75% off and get Total War Rome 2 for 80% off from the 21st of August to the 4th of September. Visit Steam and search for Total War Rome to buy now. The discount is valid for a limited time only terms and conduct. apply. Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist, and I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst or novelist.
揭晓。本集由Sega和Creative Assembly赞助播出。为了庆祝推出备受赞誉的电子游戏25周年，《全面战争：罗马2》和《全面战争：罗马重制版》将在Steam上促销。在8月21日至9月4日期间，购买罗马重制版可享75%的折扣，《全面战争：罗马2》可享80%的折扣。访问Steam并搜索Total War Rome即可立即购买。折扣仅在限定时间内有效，条款与条件适用。你好，我是国家安全记者戈登·卡雷拉，我是前中情局分析师兼小说家大卫·麦克洛斯基。
And together, we're the co-hosts of another Goalhanger show. The rest is classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of spies and secrets. We have just released an absolutely cracking new series on the infamous Colombian drug lord Pablo Escobar, how the U.S. spent decades fighting a war on drugs to bring his cocaine empire to justice. By 1989, Escobar was the seventh richest man in the world, wealthier than the entire state of Colombia. He was a husband, a father, and the most feared narco-terrorist in the world. But to the poor in his hometown of Medellin, he was kind of a hero. He built roads, houses, soccer fields, became almost a Colombian robin hood to a nation weary with a very
我们携手主持另一个Goalhanger节目：《机密档案》（The rest is classified），在这里我们为您带来来自间谍和秘密世界的最棒的故事。我们刚刚推出了一部极其精彩的新系列，讲述了臭名昭著的哥伦哥伦比亚大毒枭巴勃罗·埃斯科巴，以及美国如何花费数十年时间进行禁毒战争，将他的可卡因帝国绳之以法。到1989年时，埃斯科巴是世界上第七大富豪，比整个哥伦比亚国的财富还要多。他是一个丈夫、一个父亲，也是世界上最令人闻风丧胆的毒品恐怖分子。但对于他家乡麦德林的穷人来说，他算是个英雄。他修路、盖房子、建足球场，对于一个对极其不平等且暴力的政治和法律体系感到厌倦的国家来说，他几乎成了哥伦比亚的罗宾汉。
unequal and violent political and legal system. Over the next few weeks, we'll take you deep inside the murky world of the hunt for Escobar. Using accounts from members of the secret military units deployed to find him, will reveal how Colombian and American forces work together to track down the man who controlled a global cocaine empire. If this sounds good, we've left a clip for you at the end of this episode. Hello, welcome back to the rest of history. It is the 4th of August 1914 and the imperial German army is poised to fall on the people of Belgium. Dominic, give us some sense of what exactly this means. So this is an invasion unprecedented in human history. Von Malka is unleashing
在接下来的几周里，我们将带您深入了解搜捕埃斯科巴的暗流涌动的世界。通过部署搜寻他的秘密军事单位成员的叙述，我们将揭示哥伦比亚和美国军队如何联手追捕这个控制了全球可卡因帝国的男人。如果这听起来不错，我们在本集结尾为您留了一个片段。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest of History）。今天是1914年8月4日，德意志帝国军队正准备对比利时人民发起进攻。多米尼克，给我们讲讲这究竟意味着什么。这是一场人类历史上前所未有的入侵。小毛奇正在释放
750,000 men in three armies. They're being carried west to the border in more than 500 trains a day. Of course, railway is very important to the First World War. An absolutely mind-boggling sight for anybody who was witnessing it. These columns of grey infantry, many of them, Tom, in those spiked helmets that you like so much. A column is 50 miles long, followed by horses and trucks and artillery. So these three armies, they are commanded by three generals, Carl von Bulov, Max von Hausson, and the most compelling of them, I think, is a guy called Alexander von Kluck. And he had fought in the Franco-Prussian War. So no chicken he. Very good. I like what you did there. He looks exactly as he should. The casting agency has supplied these men have done superbly. He's got a sort of polished, shining bald head, a fearsome look and an enormous bristling moustache. And his task, he is the guy who's going to smash through Belgium, he's going to sweep around Paris, who's going to finish off the French and then turn east. And remember, he and the other generals have six weeks to do all this. So their target, he has set, von Kluk has set his men a target.
75万大军，分为三个集团军。他们每天乘坐500多列火车被运送到西部边境。当然，铁路对第一次世界大战非常重要。对于任何目睹这一幕的人来说，这都是一个绝对令人匪夷所思的景象。这些灰色的步兵纵队，Tom，其中许多人戴着你非常喜欢的带尖顶的头盔。一个纵队绵延50英里，后面跟着马匹、卡车和大炮。这三个集团军由三位将军指挥，卡尔·冯·比洛、马克思·冯·豪森，而其中最引人注目的，我认为是一个名叫亚历山大·冯·克鲁克的人。他曾参加过普法战争。所以他绝不是个新手。非常好。我喜欢你刚才的说法。他看起来完全应该是这个样子的。选角机构提供的这些人表现得太棒了。他有着一种抛光发亮的秃头，一副令人生畏的外表和一撮巨大的硬挺胡须。他的任务，他是那个要粉碎比利时、迂回包抄巴黎、解决法国人然后转向东方的人。记住，他和其它将军只有六周的时间来完成这一切。所以他们的目标，他已经设定，冯·克鲁克给他的手下设定了一个目标，
of 20 miles a day. And he says, we cannot fall behind. One day where we fall short, we have to make it good later on because the clock is ticking. And that urgency is absolutely essential to understanding what happens next. So that was the 4th of August.
即每天前进20英里。他说，我们不能落后。有一天我们没达到目标，我们以后必须补回来，因为时钟在滴答作响。这种紧迫感对于理解接下来发生的事情绝对至关重要。所以那是8月4日。
On the 5th of August, the Germans begin the assault on Liege. So this is day two. And already they're slightly falling behind their timetable. And that's the thing, isn't it, about the First World War, that people always seize on, the importance of timetables, say this is the thing about that the railway timetables
在8月5日，德国人开始了对列日（Liege）的进攻。所以这是第二天。他们已经开始稍微落后于时间表了。这就是一世纪大战的特点，不是吗？人们总是抓住时间表的重要性不放，说这就是铁路时间表
couldn't be changed or anything. But I'm guessing that this reflects the industrial quality of the combat, that industrial society depends on precisely gauged time schedules. And it must provide the German high command with a degree of pressure that no army previously had ever had. People hadn't operated to these kind of timetables. Absolutely not. I think they go into this war under greater time pressure
无法更改或类似原因的地方。但我猜这反映了战斗的工业化特质，即工业社会依赖于精确计算的时间表。这一定给德国最高指挥部带来了以前任何军队从未承受过的压力。人们以前从未按这种时间表行事。绝对没有。我认为他们投入这场战争时所承受的时间压力，
than any other competent, arguably, in history. They can't be like a sort of 18th century army who sort of have a little campaign in the summer and then go to their winter quarters do a bit of hunting on the side or something and maybe the war will take 20 years they're not charged the 12th they can hear a ticking clock
可以说是历史上任何一支军队都无法比拟的。他们不能像18世纪的军队那样，在夏天进行一小场战役，然后回到冬营，顺便打打猎什么的，也许战争会持续20年，他们不是12号出征，他们能听到一个滴答作响的时钟
in the back of their heads the whole time now liege has a garrison of 40,000 men it's far more formidable than the Germans had expected the first wave of men the Germans sent in from Westphalia and Hanover meet withering Belgian fire and are just cut down So these scenes are described in Max Hastings's brilliant book. I know you're a massive Max Hastings fan, Tom, catastrophe.
一直在脑海深处回响。现在列日拥有4万人的守军，这比德国人预期的要强大得多。德国人从威斯特伐利亚和汉诺威派出的第一波士兵遭到了比利时人猛烈的火力压制，直接被砍倒在地。所以这些场景在马克斯·海斯ings（Max Hastings）的杰作中得到了描述。我知道你是马克斯·海斯ings的超级粉丝，汤姆，那是《灾难》（Catastrophe）。
And he describes how line after line of German infantry advance on this fortress. And quote, this is a Belgian officer, we simply mowed them down. They came on almost shoulder to shoulder until as we shot them down, the fallen were heaped one on top of the other in an awful barricade of dead and wounded men. And you'll hear sentences like that again and again in this series about people who basically their officers just say this is going to be a bit like the Napoleonic Wars come on lads go for it
他描述了一排又一排的德国步兵如何向这座要塞推进。引述一位比利时军官的话，“我们简直就像割草一样把他们割倒。他们几乎肩并肩地冲上来，直到我们把他们击倒，倒下的人一层压在一层，形成了一道由死伤者组成的恐怖路障。”你会在这个系列的节目中一遍又一遍地听到这样的话，关于那些人的军官只是说这会有点像拿破仑战争，小伙子们上吧，冲啊，
and they all go for it and about 10 seconds later they're all dead in an enormous peep and the Germans I think learn that lesson pretty quickly quicker than the French and the British perhaps certainly quicker than the French I mean the French as we'll see in the next episode what's not like the Napoleonic Wars though is what happens the next day right
然后他们都冲了上去，大约10秒钟后，他们全都死在了一个巨大的尸堆里。我认为德国人很快就吸取了这个教训，比法国人和英国人更快，当然比法国人更快。我的意思是，正如我们将在下一集中看到的，法国人……然而，与拿破仑战争不同的是第二天发生的事情，对吧？
because it's the first Zeppelin raid in the history of warfare yes the first ever air attack on a European city, I read. I mean, they're literally just throwing bombs out of the Zeppelin, and they killed nine civilians in Liege. I wouldn't want to go up in a Zeppelin with a bomb. No, God, I wouldn't go in a Zeppelin at all, I think. On the 7th of August, they finally captured Leijge and the Citadel, and the final assault on Leij was led by a man who will be meeting again called Eric Ludendorff, who will be very familiar to people who heard our episode about
因为这是战争史上第一次齐柏林飞艇空袭。是的，我读到这是对欧洲城市的历史上第一次空袭。我的意思是，他们简直就是把炸弹从齐柏林飞艇上扔下来，他们在列日炸死了九名平民。我可不想带着炸弹坐齐柏林飞艇升空。不，天哪，我想我根本不会坐齐柏林飞艇。8月7日，他们终于攻占了列日和城堡，对列日的最后一次进攻由一个我们将会再次见到的人领导，名叫埃里克·鲁登道夫，听过我们关于啤酒馆暴动那一集的听众对这个人会非常熟悉。所以这是一个我认为后来在政治抉择上让自己大失所望的人。但周围的堡垒又坚持抵抗了大约10到11天，它们牵制了德国第二集团军。你知道，在这个时候，德国将军们的耳朵里几乎要冒烟了，因为他们严重落后于预定时间。他们无法像自己希望的那样快速调动所有军队。列日，尽管现在基本上被遗忘了，但在1914年的夏天，这是一个轰动全球的大新闻。它有点像马里乌波尔或类似的地方。就像乌克兰战争中的那些故事一样，人们在报纸头条上痴迷地关注着它。《三十九级台阶》的作者约翰·巴肯（John Buchan）表示，比利时人在列日的坚守是在向世界宣告，
the Beer Hall Putch. So a man who I think goes on to greatly let himself down with his political choices. But the surrounding forts fought on for about another 10-11 days, and they tied up the German Second Army. You know, at this point, kind of steam is coming out of the German general's ears because they are falling well behind their schedule. They can't move all their troops as quick as they wanted. And Liege, although it's largely forgotten now, in the summer of 1914, was a massive story. It was a bit like Mariapal or something. One of those stories from the Ukrainian war, people follow it obsessively in the newspaper headlines. John Buchan, the 39 Steps author, said that the Belgian stand at Liege was an advertisement to the world
国家和责任的古老信仰仍然能为战斗注入力量，而德国的偶像尽管光芒四射，却有着泥足。我的意思是，我们应该警告听众，这种风格的散文还会有很多。这是一个警告还是一个广告，当然是的？当你一遍又一遍地阅读它时，你会对它感到厌烦。我就是这样。我喜欢1910年代那种华丽的风格。华丽。
that the ancient faiths of country and duty could still nerve the arm for battle and that the German idol, for all its splendor, had feet of clay. I mean, we should warn listeners that there's going to be a lot of that kind of prose. Is that a warning or is that, I think, an advertisement, surely? When you read it over and over again, you get fed up with it. I did. I love that kind of 1910. Florid.
我不认为这是华丽的。我认为这是，我认为这是过度情绪化的。它有一种道德上的严肃性。确实如此，最终的结果是，这种道德上的严肃性将在铁丝网上被打得粉碎，并被老鼠啃食。好吧，既然你引入了这么残忍的话题，那我们现在就转向关于德国残暴行径的第一批报道，
I don't think it is florid. I think it's, I think it's massively over-emotional. I think it has a kind of moral earnestness. It does, which will end up, it's the kind of moral earnestness that will end up shot to pieces on barbed wire and being gnawed out by rats. Okay. Well, since you're introducing such beastly subjects, let us turn now to the very first reports of German beastliness,
用当时的术语来说。这些报道始于列日。因此，在8月4日的夜里，也就是世界大战的刚开始。德国人开进了附近的贝尔努村，他们听到夜里有不明枪声的报告，并且有谣言传到德国人那里，说他们的12名士兵被枪杀。所以第二天，他们在村里搜捕疑似罪魁祸首。他们抓了大约10个人，并把他们枪决了，其中包括一整家五口，他们
to use the terminology at the time. These reports start in the edge. So on the night at the 4th of August, so right at the very beginning of the world, war. The Germans had moved into the nearby village of Bernou, and they hear reports of unexplained gunfire in the night, and there are rumours that reach the Germans that 12 of their men have been shot. So the next day, they round up suspected culprits in the village. They get about 10 of them, and they shoot them, including an entire family of five that they
被发现在地窖里躲藏。你为什么躲在地窖里？太可疑了。我们只好除掉你们。第二天，在附近的一个小村庄圣阿德兰，一枚比利时炮弹落在了小村庄里，炸伤了一些驻扎在那里的德国人。这一次德国人说，嗯，可能泄露阵地的人是当地的教师。他们抓了他和他的家人，把他们围捕起来，然后枪决了。所以这一切为即将发生的事情定下了基调。因此，在接下来的几天里，在苏曼村，有100多名比利时平民被枪杀或刺死。在一个叫梅兰的地方，72人被赶进了一个草地，其中包括8名妇女和4名尚未成年的女孩。
found hiding in a cellar. Why are you hiding in a cellar? Very suspicious. We'll just have to get rid of you. The next day, the Germans in a nearby hamlet, Saint Adelain, a Belgian shell landed in the hamlet, and it wounded some of the Germans who were billeted there. This time the Germans said, well, probably the guy who gave a position away was the local teacher. And they got him and his family, rounded them up, and they shot them. So this all sets the tone for what is to come. So in the next few days in the village of Suman, more than 100 people, Belgian civilians, are shot or bayoneted. In a place called Melen, a 72 people herded into a meadow, including eight women and four girls who are not yet in their teens.
他们都被枪杀了。当地市长，梅兰市长赶来埋葬死者，德国人也把他枪杀了。然后他们把整个村庄烧为平地。这样的例子在任何数量的比利时小村庄里都有，因此在仅仅爆发了四天战争之后，德国人就已经处决了至少850名比利时平民。这就是自那以后一直玷污德国在第一次世界大战中记录的污点。很多人知道的一件事就是他们在比利时大失光彩。我们是怎么知道这一点的？是谁在报道这件事？是比利时人吗？是德国人吗？他们自己
And they're all shot. The local mayor, the mayor of Melen, arrived to bury the dead, and the Germans shot him too. And then they burned the whole village to the ground. And there are examples in any number of Belgian hamlets and villages, so that after just four days of the war, the Germans have executed at least 850 Belgian civilians. And this is the sort of the taint that has marked the German record in the First World War. ever since. And the one thing that a lot of people know is they disgrace themselves in Belgium. And how do we know this? Who is reporting this? Are there Belgians? Are they Germans? Are they
承认了吗？到底怎么回事？因此，比利时方面有报道。盟军报纸上有大量报道，但也有德国人的书信、德国人的日记等等。因为德国人不否认这件事正在发生。所有战争都有平民伤亡。我的意思是，想象你会打一场没有平民被枪杀的战争是完全不切实际的。但这似乎远远超出了那个范畴。德国人自己的解释是，我们一直遭到比利时平民游击队的伏击。所以有一个例子，我想马克斯·海斯ings引用了它。
admitting it? What's going on? So there are reports in the Belgians. There are lots of reports in Allied newspapers, but there are also German letters, German diary entries and so on. Because the Germans don't deny that this is happening. All wars have civilian casualties. I mean, it's completely fanciful to imagine that you'll ever fight a war in which civilians won't be shot. But this seems to go well beyond that. And the German's own explanation is, we are being ambushed all the time by Belgian civilian partisans. So there's an example, I think Max Hastings quotes it.
一个士兵写信回家，他说，我对列日“野蛮暴民造成的浩劫”感到震惊，我引述他的话。他不是在谈论德国占领者。他在谈论当地人。他说，起初人们对我们夹道欢迎，人们挥舞着某种白色桌布之类的东西作为投降的旗帜。然而，那只是一场恶毒的把戏。我们刚走过房屋，步枪枪管就从窗户里伸出来，我们的背部中枪了。
A soldier writing home, he says, I'm shocked by, I quote, the havoc wreaked by the bestial mob in Liege. He's not talking about the German occupiers. He's talking about the locals. And he says, we were greeted at first with cheers, people waving kind of white tablecloths and stuff as flags of surrender. However, that was just a malicious trick. Scarcely had we passed the houses when rifle barrels were poked out of the windows and we were shot in the back.
地窖煤洞里也有针对我们腿部的枪击。现在问题是，这些人可能不是游击队员。这些人很可能是正规的比利时部队，他们找到了掩护并伏击了德国人。但德国人认为这是一场游击战，认为这些平民是以懦夫的方式背叛了他们，趁他们背对时攻击他们。他们为什么会这么认为？好吧，这才是真正迷人之处。我想简短的回答是，德国人带着大量的历史包袱上路了。两位名叫约翰·霍恩（John Horn）和阿兰·克莱默（Alan Kramer）的爱尔兰历史学家对此做过一项精彩的研究。
There were also shots aimed at our legs from cellar coal holes. Now, the thing is, these probably weren't partisans. These were probably regular Belgian troops who had taken cover and were ambushing the Germans. But the Germans assume that this is a partisan warfare, that these are civilians who are betraying them in a cowardly way, attacking them when their backs are turned. And why are they assuming that? Well, this is the really fascinating thing. I think the short answer is the Germans have traveled with an enormous amount of historical baggage. And there's a brilliant study of this by two Irish historians called John Horn and Alan Kramer.
他们强调，德国人对1870至1871年发生的事情有着一种制度记忆，当时他们入侵了法国，占领了法国，并遭到了被称为“法兰克狙击手”（Francs-tireurs，意为自由射击手）的法国游击队的严重袭击。甚至在德国人进入比利时之前，他们就极其害怕这种情况会重演。因此，他们从列日听到的关于遭到伏击的故事加剧了他们最黑暗的恐惧，随后这些恐惧被德国报纸以类似于盟军报纸在战争期间夸大事情的方式放大。
And they emphasize the Germans had an institutional memory of what had happened in 1870, 71, when they had invaded France, occupied France, and they had come under severe attack from French partisans called Franc d'Irard, kind of free shooters. Even before the Germans went into Belgium, they are dreading that there will be a repeat of this. And so the stories they got from Liege about being ambushed exacerbate their darkest fears and they are then ramped up by German newspapers in a similar way to the way that Allied newspapers ramp stuff up during the war.
因此，德国报纸上有大量关于他们如何被自由射击手欺骗、如何遭到袭击、如何被虐待、德国士兵如何被比利时平民斩首的故事。这些都是盟军报纸讲述的关于德国人的故事的镜像。例如，在英国，有一种假设，如果你是一名士兵，去参加一场殖民战争，比如说，总会有被枪杀的风险。所以有一首吉卜丁（Kipling）的名诗，不是吗？关于“两千英镑的教育降至十卢比的杰齐亚（Jazea）”。
So German newspapers have loads of stories about how they've been tricked by frontiers, how they're being attacked, how they're being tortured, how German soldiers have been beheaded by Belgian civilians. So these are the mirror image of the stories that Allied newspapers tell about the Germans. In Britain, for instance, there's an assumption that if you're a soldier and you go to, say, a colonial war, there's always a risk that you might be shot. So there's the famous Kipling poem, isn't there? About £2,000 of education drops to a 10 rupee, Jazea.
是的。是的。这种观点认为，随时随地都可能有人从一块石头后面或其他地方朝你开枪。这大概没有成为德国文化的一部分，德国军队可能没有像作为殖民强国的英国人或法国人那样，对背后冷枪、被某个拿着劣质步枪的家伙击中的可能性习以为常。我不知道，因为德国人当然一直在西南非洲和后来的纳米比亚打殖民战争。所以他们对殖民战争并不完全陌生。我只是想知道他们是否对欧洲战争有不同的标准。
Yeah. Yeah. This idea that somebody might have a crack at you from behind a rock or something at any point. This presumably is not something that has become part of German culture in the same way, that perhaps the German military are not as inured to the possibility of, getting a bullet in the back from some guy with the cheap rifle to the degree that the British or the French who are colonial powers are. I don't know, because the Germans, of course, have been fighting colonial war in South West Africa and what becomes Namibia. So they're not completely strangers to colonial warfare. I wonder if they have a different standard for European wars.
难道你不认为他们会认为，在欧洲战争中，你基本上是在一条郊区街道或一个非常像德国村庄的村庄街道上散步吗？然后你背部中枪，这被视为完全合法且出乎意料，因为那些与你如此相似的人竟然会表现出这种行为。德皇感到愤怒，并将比利时人比作哥萨克人，不是吗？并说这是可怕的行为？这不是德国人一直渴望释放的野蛮行径的借口。德国人真诚地相信他们某种程度上被背叛了，
Do you not think that they think that in a European war, you're walking down at basically a suburban street or the street of a village that's very like a German village, really? And then you're shot in the back that it's seen as completely legitimate and unexpected, that people who are so like you would behave in this way. Kaiser's outrage and compares the Belgians to the Cossacks, doesn't he, and say that this is terrible behaviour? This is not a pretext for beastliness that the Germans were kind of itching to unleash. The Germans genuinely believe that they have been kind of betrayed in some way,
比利时人打破了战争规则。德皇，是的，完全如此。他在8月9日写道，比利时人民表现出了一种魔鬼般的、野蛮的行为，比哥萨克人好不了一点。他满嘴都是报纸那种黄色小报的老生常谈。他们一直在虐待我们的人。他们把他们殴打致死。
that the Belgians have broken the rules of warfare. The Kaiser, yeah, absolutely. The population of Belgium, he writes on the 9th of August, have behaved in a diabolical, bestial manner, and not one iota better than the Cossacks. He comes out with all the newspaper kind of tabloid cliches. They've been torturing our men. They've beaten them to death.
他说，我的意思是，德皇在与其他欧洲君主的交往中有着糟糕的外交记录，他说，告诉比利时国王，既然他的人民已经把自己置于欧洲习俗之外，他们也将受到相应的对待。我猜那句话泄露了天机，对吧？我们可能在非洲预料到这一点。但在欧洲，哦，这太令人震惊了。除非众所周知，在非洲，比利时人就是这么做的。具有讽刺意味的是。也许比利时人已经养成了习惯，汤姆。也许比利时人才是这个故事真正的恶棍。
And he says, I mean, the Kaiser who's got a terrible track record of diplomacy with the other monarchs of Europe, he says, tell the king of the Belgians, the since his people have placed themselves outside European customs, they'll be treated according. I guess that line is a giveaway, right? We might expect this in Africa. But in Europe, oh, that is shocking. Except that notoriously in Africa, this is how the Bolgians. The irony. Maybe the Belgians have got formed, Tom. Maybe the Belgians are the real villains of the story.
我的意思是，我只是在想，这也是其中的一部分吗？有一种恐惧，即……不，当然不是。比利时人要开始砍掉人们的手并强迫他们收集橡胶了。我的意思是，很明显，所有这一切都笼罩着一层阴影，比利时人在刚果犯下的暴行现在正施加在他们自己故土上的比利时人身上。我只是在想，人们对这种讽刺的忽视或觉察程度如何。好吧，你知道吗？最吸引人的是当英国报纸夸大德国的暴行时。因此，即使在今天，一些历史学家基本上还在鹦鹉学舌般地重复英国的宣传，重复这些关于德国人把婴儿串在刺刀上、砍掉妇女的手之类的故事。这些故事我认为几乎可以肯定是耸人听闻地夸大其词了，因为我的意思是，他们在进行
I mean, I'm just wondering, is that also maybe a part of it? There's kind of fear that... No, surely not. The Belgians are going to start cutting off people's hands and forcing them to collect rubber. I mean, there is obviously a kind of shadow that hangs over all of this, that atrocities that the Belgians had inflicted in the Congo are now being inflicted on the Belgians in their native land. I just wonder the degree to which people are oblivious to that irony or aware of. it. Well, do you know what? The fascinating thing is when the British papers exaggerate the German atrocities. So even today, some historians basically parrot British propaganda and repeat these stories about the Germans impaling babies on bayonets and cutting women's hands off and stuff. Stories that I think are almost certainly luridly exaggerated because, I mean, they are doing
大屠杀之类的事情，但他们并没有做所有这些。正如亚历山大·沃森（Alexander Watson）在他的书《钢铁之环》（Ring of Steel）中所指出的，这些故事是直接受到关于刚果发生的事情的报纸报道的启发。我的意思是，难以置信。他们基本上是把利奥波德国王的人在刚果所做的事情的故事拿过来，只是改了改名字，把德国人塑造成坏人，把比利时人塑造成受害者。这真的很了不起。回到德国士兵身上，我认为在公众的想象中，他们大多数人都是面容冷酷、斧削般面孔的“突击队员预备役”。
mass shootings and things, but they're not doing all this. These stories, as Alexander Watson points out in his book, Ring of Steel, these stories are dire. Directly inspired by newspaper reports about what was going on in the Congo. I mean, unbelievable. They're basically taking the stories about what, you know, King Leopold's men had been doing in the Congo and just changing the names and making the Germans the bad guys and the Belgians, the victims. It's really remarkable. To go back to the German soldiers, I think there's an image in the popular imagination that most of them are hard-faced, kind of hatchet-faced, you know, stormtroopers in waiting.
但事实上，正如霍恩和克莱默在其研究所指出的那样，很大一部分德国士兵都是十几岁的青少年。他们是仓促动员起来的。他们接受的训练非常迅速且糟糕。他们大多数人从未出过国。他们既兴奋、害怕、困惑，而且通常还酗酒。因为当他们穿过一个城镇时，他们显然会（士兵总是这样）洗劫当地的商店。他们喝上了某种比利时啤酒之类的东西。
But actually, as Horn and Kramer points out in their study, a huge proportion of the German soldiers are teenagers. They've been mobilized in haste. They've been very quickly and poorly trained. Most of them have never been abroad. They are excited, frightened, confused, and they're also often drinking heavily. Because as they go through a town, they'll obviously, you know, soldiers always do this. They'll loot the local shops. They've got stuck into the kind of Belgian beer or whatever.
所以他们有点喝高了。然后当有人向他们开枪时，他们非常非常快地就发了脾气。但这也是由高层驱动的。因此，到了8月12日，小毛奇发布了一个庄严的警告。任何涉嫌他所谓的暴行的比利时平民都将根据军事法立即被枪决。到这个时候，德国人实际上在实行一项正式的大规模报复政策。尽管海牙公约禁止这样做，但他们正在对个人行为实施集体惩罚。而且有无穷无尽的故事。
So they're a little bit tanked up. And then when somebody shoots at them, they lose their temper very, very quickly. But it's also driven from the top. So by the 12th of August, von Malker is issuing a solemn warning. Any Belgian civilian suspected of what he calls atrocities will be immediately shot under martial law. And the Germans effectively, by this point, are running a formal policy of mass reprisals. Even though this is forbidden by the Haig Convention, they're carrying out collective punishment for individual actions. And there are just endless, endless stories.
马克斯·海斯ings列举了很多。比如维泽（Visé），8月11日。德国人枪杀了25人。他们烧毁了50栋房屋。维泽，8月16日。他们枪杀了42人。一个特别严峻的故事，一个叫塔曼（Tamines）的地方，位于桑布尔河畔，在8月22日。在这里发生的事情是，德国人开进来了。村里的人公然对抗德国人，基本上不服从他们的命令。他们没有开枪，但就是不服从命令。他们没有合作。他们开始高喊“法兰西万岁”。因此，比利时后来的一项调查发现接下来发生了什么。德国人把400人赶到教堂前面。
Max Hastings lists a lot of them. them. Bazai, 11th of August. The Germans shoot 25 people. They burn 50 houses. Visei, 16th of August. They shoot 42nd people. A particularly grim story, a place called Tamin, which is on the River Sambre, on the 22nd of August. So here, what's happened is the Germans moved in. The people in the village defied the Germans, basically didn't obey their orders. They didn't shoot them, but they just didn't obey their orders. They didn't collaborate. And they started chanting, Vive la France. So a Belgian inquiry later found out what happened next. The Germans herded 400 people in front of the church.
他们把他们排成一列。他们用机关枪开火。第二天，村里剩下的人被命令在教堂集合，收集尸体并埋葬他们。德国军官站在那里一边喝香槟一边看着这一切发生。现在，比利时人召集的调查声称总共有600人在这次事件中被杀。事实上，现代历史学家将死亡人数定在400人以下。这本身就说明了一个问题，即这一切后来都被大肆渲染和夸大了，
They lined them up. They opened fire with a machine gum. And the next day, the people who were left in the village were ordered, assembled at the church to gather the bodies and bury them. And the German officers stood there drinking champagne while watching this happening. Now, the inquiry that the Belgians convened claimed that 600 people in total were killed in this. In fact, modern historians put the death toll at less than 400. And that tells its own story that so much of this was later sensationalised and exaggerated
以至于有时很难准确弄清到底发生了什么。然而，你问我们是怎么知道的，我提到了德国人的书信和日记。非常重要的一点是，德国军官自己也写到了这一点。所以有几个例子。一个叫哈里·凯斯勒伯爵（Count Harry Kessler）的人。他说，西（sea）或森（sins）的居民袭击了我们正在建桥的工兵，杀死了其中20人。作为惩罚，200名市民经军事法庭审判后被枪决。
that it is quite hard sometimes to get it exactly what happened. However, you asked about how we know, and I mentioned German letters and diaries. And it is really important to say that German officers themselves write about this. So there are a couple of examples. A guy could Count Harry Kessler. He says the inhabitants of sea or sins attacked our pioneers building a bridge. and they killed 20 of them. As a punishment, 200 citizens were court-martialed and shot.
难道还有一个故事说德国人劫持人质并将他们放在桥上以阻止桥梁被摧毁吗？我认为这完全是可能的。你完全可能会这样做。列弗（Leffer）有一个叫弗朗茨·斯泰宾（France Steibing）的人。他说，我们在枪林弹雨中从一栋房子推进到另一栋房子，子弹来自每一栋建筑。我们逮捕了所有男性居民。他们在街上同样被处决了。
Isn't there a story also that the Germans take hostages and put them on the bridges to stop them being destroyed? Which I think is perfectly plausible. You might well do that. There's a guy in Leffer called France Steibing. He says, we pushed on past house after house under fire from every building. We arrested all the male inhabitants. They were similarly executed in the street.
我们只饶恕了15岁以下的儿童、老人和妇女。有故事说，不是吗？不仅是妇女的手被砍断了，连儿童的手也被砍断了。巴黎不是有一个美国人向比利时军队或某个正在散布这些杀害儿童故事的人打赌吗，他说，“给我确凿的证据证明有任何儿童被杀害？”我想这是一个一直没有结果的赌局。
We only spared children under 15 old people and women. There are stories, aren't there? say that it's not just women who have their hands chopped off, that children as well are having their hands chopped off. And isn't there an American in Paris who offers a bet to the Belgian army or something who are putting out these stories that children are being massacred and says, you know, give me hard evidence that any child has been killed? And I think that that's a kind of a bet that is left standing.
是否有确凿的证据表明儿童被屠杀与否？没有。我认为有些儿童确实被卷入了这些枪击事件中。我不认为，我不认为数量为零。遭到针对。没有遭到针对。他们当然没有遭到针对。
Is there a hard evidence that children are massacred or not? No. I think some children are definitely swept up in these shooting. I don't think it's, I don't think there are zero. Targeted. There's no targeted. They're not targeted. Of course they're not targeted.
大约有5500人在比利时被杀，法国还有一千人。大约15000人被驱逐到德国。一些历史学家说，天哪，这太可怕了。这是纳粹主义的预演。但实际上，你知道，你问人们是否被蓄意针对。这是一种向彻底野蛮状态的坠落吗？我不这么认为。
And probably about 5,500 people were killed in Belgium, another thousand in France. And about 15,000 people were probably deported to Germany. And some historians have said, gosh, this is dreadful. This is a preview of Nazism. But actually, you know, you ask about our people being deliberately targeted. Is this a sort of descent into total savagery? I don't think it is.
如果你看亚历山大·沃森的书，他引用了许多人的话，这些人谈到了执行这些报复行动。所以他有一个精彩的例子，讲的是一个名叫威廉·施韦格（Wilhelm Schweiger）的步兵，他来自德国西北部的一个小镇，他在战斗中阵亡，留给未婚妻一本字。
If you look at Alexander Watson's book, he quotes a lot of people who talk. who talk about carrying out these reprisals. So he's got a brilliant example of a rifleman called Wilhelm Schweiger, who's from a small town in northwestern Germany, and he was killed and he left a diary for his fiancé. And he describes coming under attack on a night patrol, and he says, you know, we found the house that we thought we were being shot at from, and we burned it down, we shot everybody who came out.
他描述了在夜间巡逻时遭到袭击，他说，“你知道，我们找到了那座我们以为遭到枪击的房子，我们把它烧毁了，我们枪杀了所有走出来的人。”
And he says, you know, we're really angry, we, all this kind of thing. But then he goes on to say, it was terrible, quite terrible. I did my duty and I obeyed orders, but it's dreadful, if only this horrible war at an end. And you see that a lot, I think, in German letters and diaries. The people say, it's dreadful that we have to do this. I don't enjoy doing it at all. You know, it's not an exercise in sadism. It's very different from the sentiments in the Third Reich, where you're being told that what you're doing
他说，“你知道，我们真的很生气，我们，所有这些事情。”但接着他又说，“这太可怕了，相当可怕。我履行了我的职责，我服从了命令，但这太可怕了，要是这场可怕的战争能结束就好了。”我想你在德国人的书信和日记中经常看到这一点。人们说，我们不得不这样做真是太可怕了。我一点也不喜欢这样做。你知道，这不是一场虐待狂的锻炼。这与第三帝国的那些情绪截然不同，在第三帝国，你被告知你正在做的事情
is kind of important racial hygienic cleansing, and it's a noble thing to do and all of this. These people feel bad about what they're doing. They all know they feel bad about it. The officers feel bad about it because the officers, as Watson says, they have an aristocratic honor culture. They see themselves as chivalric knights. He gives an example of another guy, Major General Kosh. His division shot more than 200 Belgian civilians.
是一种相当重要的种族卫生净化，是一件高尚的事情，诸如此类。这些人对他们所做的事感到难过。他们都知道他们为此感到难过。军官们也为此感到难过，因为正如沃森所说，军官们有一种贵族荣誉文化。他们视自己为骑士。他举了另一个人的例子，少将科什（Kosh）。他的师枪杀了200多名比利时平民。
And he wrote to his wife and he said, you know, we're doing this and we have to do it. But I hope we can stop soon because, and I quote, we're not Huns and we don't want to sully the honor of the German name. So it's not as bad, for instance, as the behavior of the French in. the peninsula war against guerrero or napoleon's troops in italy actually alexander Watson in his book makes precise at this point he says if you look at previous european wars on a similar scale there are far more civilian atrocities it's actually an interesting example of how this sounds a weird thing to say but i think the value of human life increased
他写信给妻子说，“你知道，我们正在这样做，我们必须这样做。但我希望我们能快点停下来，因为（我引述）我们不是匈奴，我们不想玷污德国名字的荣誉。”所以它并不像，例如，法国人在半岛战争中对游击队的行为，或者拿破仑的军队在意大利的行为那么糟糕。实际上，亚历山大·沃森在他的书中精确地指出了这一点，他说，如果你看看以前规模相似的欧洲战争，平民暴行的数量要多得多。这其实是一个有趣的例子，说明这听起来可能有点奇怪，但我认为人类生命的价值提高了
in the course of the 19th century however yeah having said that i mean i suppose you could argue that this is because it's because the british or the french aren't actually invading anywhere But the allies are not doing this. It's only the Germans who are doing this. Foting on home territory. There's a lot more bad behavior to come by the Austrians, by the Russians and so on, almost always on enemy soil. And that's because if you're fighting outside your homeland, you tend to behave badly. If you're fighting on home turf, you tend to behave much better.
在19世纪的过程中。然而，话虽如此，我的意思是，你可能会认为这是因为英国人或法国人实际上并没有入侵任何地方。但盟国没有这样做。只有德国人在这样做。在本土作战。奥地利人、俄罗斯人等还有很多糟糕的行为要发生，几乎总是在敌方领土上。那是因为如果你在祖国以外作战，你往往表现得很糟糕。如果你在本土作战，你往往表现得好得多。
Was it within the allied repertoire to behave badly? I think if anybody listened to this who is from Asia or Africa, would tell you. say, come on. Well, Ireland, how does it compare to British behaviour in the War of Independence that we did a series about earlier? Exactly, we've just done that series. Now, of course, the numbers are much smaller because the whole conflict is on a smaller scale. But if you look at the behaviour of the Black and Tanzan Island, is it in the British national character to carry out reprisals of a similar kind? Clearly it is. What would the Boers say about this? Yeah, and the British in that burn down a section of cork. And there is a certain degree of
恶劣行为在盟军的惯例范围内吗？我想，如果任何来自亚洲或非洲的人听到这话，都会告诉你。会说，拜托。那么爱尔兰呢？这与我们之前做过系列的独立战争中的英国行为相比如何？没错，我们刚刚做那个系列。当然，数字要小得多，因为整个冲突的规模更小。但是如果你看看黑白军团在爱尔兰的行为，进行类似性质的报复是英国国民性格的一部分吗？显然是的。布尔人会对此说些什么呢？是的，英国人在那里烧毁了一部分的科克。比利时也确实有一定程度的
burning things down in Belgium, isn't there? It has to be said, the British don't, for instance, burn down libraries. I mean, the Germans have been very poor at PR throughout this entire episode, but there's one incident in particular, which is disastrous for their worldwide reputation. And this is a story about a library, about the medieval university of Louvain or Leuven, which is the oldest university in the low countries. And basically what happened in this place, which is now, I mean, it's called Louvant at the time, but now I think people call it Leuven.
焚烧房屋，不是吗？必须指出的是，英国人不会例如烧毁图书馆。我的意思是，德国人在整个事件中的公关表现一直很糟糕，但有一个事件尤其对他们的全球声誉是灾难性的。这是一个关于图书馆的故事，关于低地国家最古老的大学——中世纪鲁汶大学（Louvain 或 Leuven）的故事。基本上在这个地方（当时叫Louvrant，但现在我想人们叫它Leuven）发生的事情是，
There were reports of gunshots in this town, and the German soldiers, run completely amok. They lose their discipline. They're beating up people in the streets, bayoneting them and stuff. They break into the university library and they set it on fire. And firemen arrive to tackle the blaze and the Germans hold them back. They want to watch it burn. And basically a quarter of a million books went up in smoke and hundreds of, you know, priceless medieval manuscripts. And then the fire spread overnight into the old city of Leven and loads of it was destroyed, hundreds of people killed, all of this kind of. a thing. And this is the one incident that goes around the world and leads to people saying
小镇上出现了枪声的报告，德国士兵完全失去了理智。他们失去了纪律。他们在街上殴打人们，用刺刀刺他们等等。他们闯入大学图书馆并放火焚烧。消防员赶来扑灭大火，德国人却把他们拦住。他们想看着它燃烧。基本上，二十五万本书化为灰烬，数百份无价的中世纪手稿也化为灰烬。然后大火在一夜之间蔓延到鲁汶老城，大量建筑被毁，数百人被杀，诸如此类的事情。这就是传遍全世界并导致人们这样说的事件
they're the Huns, they're barbarians, their book burners, all of this. And as you say, it's a particular disaster, maybe particularly in Britain, where intellectuals and opinion formers almost have a cultural cringe towards Germany. Germany's cultural and intellectual achievements, the sense that Germany is the most highly educated nation in the world. I mean, it's not an an accurate impression. But it is a disaster, isn't it? Because the spectacle of German troops destroying a library, it detonates that image. It does completely. And so the remarkable turnaround in the image of Germany in Britain between the sort of the summer before the war started, the summer of 1914 and then the end of the year, Max Hastings quotes this British naval cadet. He writes in his
他们是匈奴人，他们是野蛮人，他们是焚书者，诸如此类。正如你所说，这是一场特殊的灾难，也许特别是在英国，知识分子和舆论制造者对德国几乎有一种文化上的自卑感。德国在文化和知识上的成就是有目共睹的，人们觉得德国是世界上教育程度最高的国家。我的意思是，这并不是一个准确的印象。但这确实是一场灾难，不是吗？因为德军摧毁一座图书馆的景象，彻底粉碎了那种形象。确实如此。因此，在战争爆发前的那个夏天——1914年的夏天，到年底这短短几个月里，英国对德国的形象发生了非同寻常的转变，马克斯·黑斯廷斯引用了一位英国海军军校学员的话。他在日记中写道
diary at the end of August. He says, if their army is capable of doing what it is doing, then the rest of the race must be the same. From now onwards, I shall regard every German, man, woman and child from the Kaiser downwards as a willful savage. The use of that kind of language, the Germans are Philistines, they're barbarians, they're savages. That becomes very common. I mean, that's the kind of language you might expect from a young man. But you do also start to get it among British writers and intellectual scientists who previously had been in awe of German cultural achievements. I mean, it's incredible how fast that sense switches. Obviously, the Kipling and the people like that and the Buckens and whatnot, people who are basically co-opted for the war effort
八月底时写道。他说，如果他们的军队有能力做出它正在做的事情，那么这个种族的其余部分也一定是这样的。从今以后，我将把每一个德国人——男人、女人、孩子，从德皇开始——都视为一个蓄意妄为的野蛮人。这种语言的使用，即德国人是非利士人，他们是野蛮人，他们是未开化的人。这变得非常普遍。我的意思是，这是你可能会从一个年轻男子那里听到的那种语言。但你也开始在英国作家、知识分子和科学家中听到这种说法，而他们以前曾对德国的文化成就敬畏有加。我的意思是，这种感觉转变的速度之快令人难以置信。显然，吉卜林和诸如此类的人，还有巴金之流，基本上都被拉拢去参与战争宣传了
and who previously, as you say, they'd been perfectly happy to go and give like a lecture at the University of Heidelberg. But by 1915, they're saying, I'll never have a German book in the house again. These people are absolute savages. They're the worst, the worst. So all of this catastrophic, I think, for Germany's reputation. Now, meanwhile, their juggernaught has been rolling through Belgium. Now, they have fallen behind the timetable, but they're still making amazing progress. So they are sometimes hitting their 20 miles a day target.
而在此之前，正如你所说，他们非常乐意去海德堡大学作个讲座什么的。但到了1915年，他们却说，我再也不会让一本德国书进屋了。这些人绝对是野蛮人。他们是最坏的，最坏的。所以所有这些，我认为对德国的声誉来说都是一场灾难。现在，与此同时，他们的巨兽正席卷比利时。现在，他们的进度落后于时间表了，但他们仍在取得惊人的进展。所以他们有时能达到一天推进20英里的目标。
And by the 19th of August, so what are we? We are two weeks into the war. They reach the suburbs of Brussels. It's a brilliant description by an American journalist called Richard Harding Davis, who was in Brussels at the time. And he describes the scenes that the streets are already crowded with the wagons of refugees who fled from eastern Belgium.
到了8月19日，我们现在处在什么阶段？我们已经进入战争两周了。他们到达了布鲁塞尔郊区。美国记者理查德·哈丁·戴维斯对当时身处布鲁塞尔的场景进行了精彩的描述。他描述了这样的景象：街道上已经挤满了从比利时东部逃难而来的难民的马车。
sort of three generations of people. And he says the tears rolled down their brown, tanned faces. To the people of Brussels who crowded around them, they spoke in hushed, broken phrases, the terror of what they'd escaped and what they'd seen was upon them. Now, people are preparing barricades. They're preparing for a great siege. But overnight, on the 19th, 20th, the king of Belgium sends orders, he says, I don't want to see my capital destroy by fighting. There's no point. The Germans are going to win. It's better to surrender intact now and hopefully we're regain it later. So at 11 o'clock in the next morning, this guy Harding Davis, this American guy, he watches the German advance guard coming down, ironically maybe, the boulevard, Waterloo.
可以说是三代同堂。他说，泪水顺着他们晒得黑里透红的脸庞滚落下来。对于围拢过来的布鲁塞尔市民，他们用压抑、断断续续的话语诉说着，他们死里逃生的恐惧以及所见所闻深深地烙印在他们心头。现在，人们正在准备路障。他们正在为一场大战围城做准备。但在19日的那个夜晚到20日，比利时国王下达了命令，他说，我不想看到我的首都毁于战火。没有意义。德国人会赢的。最好现在完好无损地投降，希望我们以后能夺回来。因此，第二天早上11点，这个叫哈丁·戴维斯的美国家伙，看着德国先头部队沿着或许带有讽刺意味的滑铁卢大道开过来。
And he says, the advance guard was three men, a captain and two privates on bicycles. Their rifles were slung across their shoulders. They rode unwarily with as little concern as the members of a touring club out for a holiday. So these guys and bikes come down. And then behind them comes the might of General von Kloch's army. Here's an amazing description. This was a machine, endless, tireless, with the delicate organization of a watch and the brute power of a steamroller.
他说，先头部队是三个人，一个上尉和两个骑自行车的士兵。他们的步枪斜挎在肩膀上。他们骑得毫无戒备，就像一群出来度假的旅游俱乐部的成员一样轻松。所以这些骑自行车的家伙过来了。然后紧随其后的是克鲁克将军军队的强大力量。这是一个令人惊叹的描述：这是一个源源不断、不知疲倦的机器，既有手表般精密的组织，又有蒸汽碾路机般的蛮力。
And for three days and three nights through Brussels, it roared and rumbled the cataract of molten lead. That is so good. And it so sums up. Everything that people admired about Germany, and you can see how that admiration could turn into fear, the idea of it being as delicate, watch and as powerful as a steamroller. I mean, it's perfect. He has this description. They're singing
连续三天三夜，它在布鲁塞尔咆哮着、轰鸣着，宛如熔铅的瀑布。写得太棒了。它完美地总结了一切。人们对德国赞赏的一切，你也能看出这种赞赏是如何演变成恐惧的，它既有手表的精细，又有蒸汽碾路机的威力，这种理念。我的意思是，太完美了。他有这样一段描述：他们在唱歌
the Germans, Vaterland, mine Vaterland. He says their iron-shod boots beating out the time like that blows from a giant pile driver. The sight was uncanny, inhuman, a force of nature like a landslide, a tidal wave or lava sweeping down a mountain. It was not of this earth, but mysterious, ghostlike. It carried all the mystery and menace of a fog rolling towards. you across the sea. That's brilliant. And so Brussels has fallen. Ahead lie the fields of Flanders, beyond them, the valley of the Marn and beyond that, the ultimate prize, Paris. But Dominic, as you have been saying, the clock is always ticking down. And I suppose a huge question is, will the Germans make it in time? And also, an even more important question, what have our own
德国人唱着《祖国，我的祖国》。他说，他们铁底靴踏出的节奏就像巨型打桩机的锤击一样。那景象诡异、不似人形，就像山崩、海啸或熔岩顺山而下那样的自然之力。这不属于这个世界，而是神秘、幽灵般的。它带着浓重的神秘感和威胁感，就像大雾在海上向你翻滚过来。太精彩了。就这样，布鲁塞尔沦陷了。前方是法兰德斯的原野，再过去是马恩河谷，而越过那里，便是终极的奖赏——巴黎。但是，多米尼克，正如你一直所说的那样，倒计时一直在进行。我想最大的问题是：德国人能及时赶到吗？还有一个更重要的问题，我们自己的勇敢同胞——英国人，又会怎么样呢？如果你想一口气听完的不仅是下一集，而是这部史诗级系列的全部六集，那么你可以加入我们专属的铁血条顿师：‘历史剩余俱乐部’，网址是therestisistory.com。阿菲达·扎恩。阿菲达·扎恩。嗨，又见面了。我是‘机密剩余’节目的戴维。以下是我们之前提到的那段剪辑：战胜毒品是我们的事业，是一项正义的事业。在你们的帮助下，我们将取得胜利。麦德林贩毒集团头目巴勃罗·埃斯科巴。
plucky countrymen, the British? If you want to hear not just a next episode, but all six episodes of this epic series in one go, then you can join our very own crack-tutonic division. The Rest is History Club at the Rest is History.com. Afida Zane. Afida Zane. Hi again. It's David from The Rest is Classified. Here's that clip we mentioned earlier. Victory over drugs is our cause, a just cause. And with your help, we are going to win. Pablo Escobar, the head of the Medellin drug cartel.
世界的第14个，也就是人类。在许多方面，他是个恐怖分子。这是一种集中在少数人和犯罪分子手中的经济权力。他们通过勒索得不到的东西，就会通过谋杀来获取。我不认为他表达了任何遗憾。他试图把自己塑造成一个平民英雄，这种左翼的、革命的江洋大盗。麦德林几乎所有人都支持贩毒分子，不支持的人要么死了，要么成了目标。如果你宣战，你就得预料到国家会作出反应。
The world's 14th, which is man. He was, in many ways, a terrorist. This is an economic power concentrated in a few hands and in criminal minds. What they cannot obtain by blackmail, they get by murder. And I don't think he expressed any regret at all. He tries to portray himself as a man of the people, this kind of like leftist, revolutionary outlaw. Nearly everyone in Medellin supports the traffickers, those who don't are either dead or targets. If you declare war, you've got to expect the state to respond.
这是他做得过头的一刻。自周末以来，麦德林已经发生了13起爆炸事件。到1987年底，波哥大基本上成了一个战区。美国对国际反毒品努力的开支将从1989年的不到3亿美元增长到1991年的7亿多美元。一个确切的事实是，在哥伦比亚，没有人能真正免受贩毒集团刺客的威胁。这是一场甚至连阻止可卡因流通都不是其目标的冲突。其目的是打倒这个毒品恐怖分子。
This is the moment where he goes too far. 13 bombs have gone off to Medellin since the weekend. By the end of 87, Bogota is essentially a war zone. U.S. spending for international anti-drug efforts is going to grow from less than $300 million in 1989 to more than $700 million by 1991. It is the certain knowledge that no one is really safe in Colombia from drug cartel assassins. It's a conflict where the goal wasn't even to stop, the flow of cocaine. It was to bring down this narco-terrorist.
从这一刻起，一切都背离了他。他一直在构建的一切正在土崩瓦解。要收听完整单集，请在您获取播客的任何地方收听‘机密剩余’。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Everything has turned against him after this point. The whole thing he was building is collapsing. To hear the full episode, listen to the rest is classified wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
从这一点开始，一切都对他的不利。他一直在构建的整个大厦正在坍塌。要收听完整单集，请在您获取播客的任何平台上收听《The Rest is Classified》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。